What's up, friends? Thanks for being
here. Warm welcome as always, especially
if you are new. Thank you for being
here. Tonight, we're going to be looking
at a presentation that celebrity SDA
pastor Doug Bachelor did uh a couple of
years ago, or I guess a few of years ago
at this point, uh titled, "Is Sunday
Sacred?" wherein he misrepresents the
Christian church, but more specifically
first day sabotarians.
I'm going to try and do my best tonight
to be clear and thorough as I am fully
aware of the sway of this doctrine in
particular within Adventism as well as
the sour taste that it has left in many
former Adventists mouths. However, it is
important and it's important that we go
where the truth leads. And so that is
where I'm going to be coming from
tonight. To do that, it is going to take
time. I think you guys are starting to
notice a uh pattern here when it comes
to live streams. This will be a
two-parter. Part two will happen next
week because uh this is not a soundbite
two-s sentence topic despite the SDA
church thinking such. This is a whole
Bible topic that needs to be looked at
much more deeply than just throwing out
proof texts. whether you're on the for
side, the against side, whatever side,
um it it requires a lot more than that.
So, first I want to say I know there
will be lots of people that disagree
with me on this, not just Adventists.
The ears of a lot of former Adventists
are going to be a little twisted, and I
get that, but track with me, please,
because the SDA church has hijacked the
doctrine of the Sabbath. Yes, hijacked
the doctrine and they have left a sour
taste in lots of people's mouths,
leaving many to just simply concede the
doctrine to them. But not here. That is
not the approach or belief here. The
Sabbath is a beautiful doctrine when
rightly understood, which is why I
concede no theology, none, to the SDA
church. And I am of the opinion that the
genetic fallacy should not be employed
to say, "Well, because they teach it
that makes it wrong." Well, no. It could
be their uh understanding of it or a
variety of other things. Some might be
surprised to hear me say that, but it's
because they ripped off other people
that came before them and then twisted
those people's claims and arguments to
try and fit with the great controversy
worldview. And they don't. Um, so the
problem isn't the Sabbath, just like the
problem isn't the law, for example,
Romans 7:12. The problem is the SDA
church's twisting of these things to fit
their extra-biblical pre-earth origin
story. But you don't have to agree with
me and my convictions. The goal of
tonight is to demonstrate that the SDA
church has no clue what they criticize
and that when they emphatically assert,
and when I say they, by the way, folks,
I I know that when I say organization,
it's like, well, who who necessarily is
they? Um, we're talking about the
organization's official claims and
teachings put forth by people like their
scholars or even tonight. I know Doug
Bachelor is not a theologian or a
scholar, but he has the stamp of
approval from the organization. Um, and
so that is who I'm referring to when
when I say that. Um, but nevertheless,
uh, when they emphatically assert that
Christians have no biblical basis for
worshiping on the first day, understand
that they evidence they do not know what
they are talking about.
So take that as you see fit. But in my
opinion, what I'm going to present
tonight and next week is the strongest
apologetic against the SDA church's
theology of the Sabbath. And Christians
for 2,000 years have understood it long
before the SDA church was around to
supposedly correct everyone else with
present truth light uh and warn them
that they've been deceived by Satan and
and all this stuff. So as the mantra
goes, this will not be answering
Adventism's private interpretation. I
simply stand on the shoulders of giants
and am more than indebted to the
wellspring of Christians that came
before me as well as many who are
currently living of whom we will
reference some tonight. So sharing is
caring. Take it or leave it. But I
believe this to truly be the death kneel
to the position uh that they hold. And I
do mean that. I'm I'm not exaggerating.
So, as I mentioned, SDA pioneers, they
borrowed arguments and claims from
people that came before them, but then
twisted them to fit their system.
Namely, that the people they borrowed
from were all right about virtually
everything they claimed about the
Sabbath being perpetual, made for man,
etc. Yet they were all supposedly
universally wrong on the day apparently
which shows that the SDA pioneers didn't
understand the crux of the position
which is new creation because the first
day memorial is a central part of that
whole thing. So we will be getting into
that tonight. Now something that has to
be understood up front as well. One of
the root issues in this particular
discussion, but really across the board
with them, is hermeneutic methodology.
Hermeneutics is just the fancy word for
interpretation method. Everybody has
one. The SDA church loves everything in
sound bites and proof texts and on this
particular uh this particular topic.
They also inconsistently utilize what is
called the verbatim fallacy, but only
applying it when they see fit. The
verbatim fallacy, as you'll hear many
times tonight from Doug, is the claim
that something must be verbatim stated
in the Bible in order for it to be
present in the Bible. A common uh
example of this is when they'll
rhetorically ask, "Show me one verse in
the Bible that says, "Go to church on
Sunday." Well, that's not how this
position is arrived at. So,
if that standard was applied across the
board for SDA teaching, the
investigative judgment's gone, the
health message is gone, the heavenly
trio is gone, and on and on. For
example, the claim that the mark of the
beast will be a national turned
international Sunday law headed up by
the papacy. They hop all over scripture
to try and use deduction, inference,
etc. to make it work because it isn't
verbatim stated in the text. Yet on this
topic, all of a sudden, they want to
hold others to the verbatim fallacy, a
standard they don't consistently hold in
their own framework. So, be on the
lookout for that tonight. The claim is
not that a single text somewhere says
verbatim the Sabbath was changed to
Sunday or go to church on Sunday. This
is a really remedial hermeneutic and way
of reading the Bible because every
teaching of scripture is not necessarily
verbatim stated but is still present in
the text. Nonetheless, God expects us to
use our higher critical faculties to
study the word and grow to the meat, not
just beyond spiritual milk. So to get
started, I want to do a little bit of
groundwork to set the stage for those
who are not as keyed in on this. If
you're a Christian, you don't know much
about Adventism. Um,
this will definitely help you out and
give you some idea as to where Doug is
coming from in this presentation. Like I
said, everyone was not in the dark on
the doctrine of the Sabbath until the
SDA church came along, which is a common
charge that they like to make. If you
are a former Adventist, you will
especially know how this narrative is
propped up in the SDA church. They make
this charge because Ellen White claimed
to be shown the truth of the Sabbath in
vision, which included details like it
being the great test in the end and that
she saw the Ten Commandments in heaven
except not the first time and yada yada.
Notice some of the things she claims
here because again, Doug is going to uh
bring these presuppositions to the table
in his talk which will influence claims
he makes about scripture. Present
truth, August 1st, 1849. She states,
quote,
I saw that the present test on the
Sabbath could not come until the
mediation of Jesus in the holy place was
finished.
And he had passed within the second
veil. Therefore, Christians who fell
asleep before the door was opened in the
most holy when the midnight cry was
finished at the seven month 1844, and
had not kept the true Sabbath, now rest
in hope. for they had not the light and
the test on the Sabbath, which we now
have since that door was opened. Close
quote. So, she claims to be shown in
vision from God that their understanding
and teaching on the Sabbath is a present
test which couldn't come until Jesus
supposedly entered the into the most
holy place in heaven for the first time
in 1844 to begin the investigative
judgment. and that people who died prior
to this revelation and did not have this
supposed truth, they rest in hope
because they didn't have this light and
test on the Sabbath. So Christians
understand it isn't just about going to
church on Saturday for them. It runs
much deeper in the psyche of an
Adventist. It is a test of loyalty. It
is the dividing line between the saved
and the unsaved. Those who are truly
loyal to God and those who are not.
Which is why in her book Evangelism,
she also said, quote,
"The Lord has been pleased to give his
people the third angel's message as a
testing message to bear to the world.
John beholds a people distinct and
separate from the world who refuse to
worship the beast or his image, who bear
God's sign, keeping holy his Sabbath,
the seventh day to be kept holy as a
memorial of the living God, the creator
of heaven and earth. of them. The
apostle writes, "He or they that keep
the commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus." Close quote.
So part of their novel gospel, their
three angels messages entails them
taking this Sabbath light and Sabbath
truth to the world. It is a testing
message. Meaning once you hear it, you
have a choice to make. It is a life
ordeath issue. When they try and tell
you, "No, it's just out of love for
God." That isn't the full picture. They
may be doing so because they think that
uh in part uh but deep down they think
their salvation hangs on this. Notice
she also texts in the Sabbath seal
doctrine that the seal of the ten
commandments is contained within the
fourth and all those who observe it as
they have put forth. I emphasize that as
they have put forth supposedly have the
sign of truly following God. Again,
evangelism, page 226. Quote,
I am instructed to say, gather from the
scriptures the proofs that God has
sanctified the seventh day, and let
these proofs be read before the
congregation. Let those who have not
heard the truth be shown that all who
turn aside from a plain, thus sayeth the
Lord, must suffer the the result of
their course. In all ages, the Sabbath
has been the test of loyalty to God. It
is a sign between me and the children of
Israel forever, the Lord declares. Close
quote.
So now she contradicts herself. In 1849,
she claims those who died before this
light had been given to her were resting
in hope because they didn't have what?
The light and present test on the
Sabbath. Yet here she claims that in all
ages it's been a test of loyalty, trying
to cite Exodus 31, which uh doesn't say
that it's a test of loyalty. But again,
great controversy. page 605. Quote,
"The Sabbath will be the great test of
loyalty, for it is the point of truth,
especially controverted, when the final
test shall be brought to bear upon men,
then the line of distinction will be
drawn between those who serve God and
those who serve him not. While the
observance of the false Sabbath in
compliance with the law of the state
contrary to the fourth commandment will
be in a vowel of allegiance to a power
that is in opposition to God. The
keeping of the true Sabbath in obedience
to God's law is an evidence of loyalty
to the creator.
While one class by accepting the sign of
submission to earthly powers receive the
mark of the beast, the other choosing
the token of allegiance to divine
authority receive the seal of God. Close
quote.
So when a national turned international
Sunday law comes down the pike, it will
be the final test of loyalty for
mankind.
Even though it was a test in all ages
already, apparently it will really,
really be a test when this happens.
And what I'm going to be presenting
tonight is considered the false Sabbath,
which if you recall when I responded to
Mark Finley some months back, we looked
at where she claimed Sunday is Satan's
Sabbath.
That he crafted it by conspiring in a
diabolical council meeting in outer
space to try and deceive people and
ultimately attack Adventists. And
worshiping on Sunday is apparently going
to be made the law worldwide, which will
be the mark of the beast when this
happens. If you then follow suit and
observe it. Last quote here. Great
controversy. Page 52. Quote.
In the first centuries, the true Sabbath
had been kept by all Christians.
They were jealous for the honor of God.
And believing that his law was
immutable. They zealously guarded the
sacredness of its precepts. But with
great subtlety, Satan worked through his
agents to bring about his object, that
the attention of the people might be
called to the Sunday. It was made a
festival in honor of the resurrection of
Christ. Religious services were held
upon it. Yet, it was regarded as a day
of recreation,
the Sabbath still being sacredly
observed. Close quote.
So, especially remember this quote
tonight, folks. Remember this quote.
the claim that in the first centuries
plural the seventh day Sabbath was
supposedly kept by all Christians.
Sunday was a product of Satan that
worked through his agents to that that
he worked through his agents to uh to
bring about calling people's attention
to it. All the early Christians
supposedly kept Saturday sacred and the
first day was seen as a recreation day,
a recreational worship day. Spoiler
alert, this is not true as we will see.
So understand in the SDA's eyes to not
be doing what they are doing they see as
willful disobedience.
Thus if you disagree with them they will
think you're advocating for disobedience
to God.
Which is why the root issue on this
topic is not just throwing other proof
texts back at them.
It's demonstrating no, it isn't willful
disobedience to disagree with their
faulty interpretation of the text.
because that's the root problem. Not the
law, not the Sabbath, not obedience, but
their faulty interpretation and
application of the text. But that is the
underlying framework that Doug's message
is coming from. For those who may not
understand that, understand that these
statements and others are the lesser
light that is supposedly shining onto
the Bible to make it clear as to what's
being said, what's going on, etc. in the
biblical text and what is supposedly
coming in the future. So, with that in
mind, let's get into it here. Starting
at the beginning, Genesis chapter 2, God
made the world in six days. No, really,
seven days because he wasn't done
creating until after
the full week. He made one more thing.
He made a day. Thus, the heavens and the
earth were finished and all the host of
them. And on the seventh day, God ended
his work which he had made. And he
rested the seventh day from all his work
which he had done. And God blessed the
seventh day and sanctified it. Made it
holy because in it he rested from all
his work which God created and made. He
did not make it holy for himself. He
made it holy for man to remember. The
Bible says the Sabbath was made for man.
It doesn't say the Sabbath was made for
Jews. The word there is anthropulse. It
means mankind, humanity.
And it's first time also you're going to
find the word seven mentioned three
times. It says seven seven7. It's a
number associated with God the seventh
day, the seventh day, the seventh day.
Very specific. You get to the last book
of the Bible. It's got another number
associated with man who was made on the
sixth day and it's 666. So you got this
contest between the worship of God and
the worship of man that goes on through
the Bible. Now you go to the ten
commandments. You find them in Exodus
20:8. Remember the Sabbath day to keep
it holy. Six days you should labor and
do all of your work, but the seventh day
is the Sabbath of the Lord your God. In
it you shall not do any work, your son
or your daughter, so forth. But it's
very clearly says, do all your work, six
days, seventh day, holy time. This is
one of the ten commandments
spoken by God's voice. They are not 10
suggestions. They're not 10
recommendations. God spoke with his own
voice, wrote with his own finger, his
eternal law, moral law for all his
people, for all the world for that
matter. So which day is the seventh day?
Some people say, well, you can't really
know just using the Bible. Uh well,
start with the dictionary. That's not
the Bible dictionary. Seventh day,
Saturday, seventh day of the week. You
go to the Bible tells us that Jesus was
crucified on the preparation day which
we know to be Friday. Uh then it says
they went home and they kept the Sabbath
according to the commandment the seventh
day and then he rose they came to the
tomb early Sunday morning the first day.
People call it Easter Sunday. So you can
even look in the Bible it's pretty clear
inund it's not this way in English. In
English, we call the seventh day
Saturday, but in a lot of other
languages, Spanish, how do you say
Saturday? Sabado. Portuguese.
Sabado. Russian.
Subota. I got some Russians here. And
105 languages of the world. The word for
the seventh day of the week, what we
call Saturday, is Sabbath day. Isn't
that interesting? So, why is everyone
going to church on Sunday? Is Sunday
sacred? Where did that happen?
All right. So, I actually appreciate him
saying that God created a day on the
seventh day because that means he was
working, right, Doug? Which pos uh poses
serious problems for your guys' claim
regarding the eternality of the seventh
day Sabbath?
Because a common claim made by the SDA
church is that the Sabbath is eternal.
Not just that the substance of the
command is eternal. They were getting
this from other people, by the way,
folks. But they misunderstood what those
people were saying.
It's not just that the substance of the
command is eternal, which is that God is
worthy and do a portion of his image
bears time to step away from taking uh
the command to work and subdue the
earth.
No, they claim the seventh day Sabbath
was being observed in heaven prior to
the creation of the earth. Yet here Doug
says the seventh day was created at a
point after the creation of the earth.
Days are also dependent upon the lights
that God created the sun and the moon
which are also parts of creation. So
there are a number of problems with this
claim. But Doug, I agree. The Sabbath
was made for man. It's interesting
though that you guys never cite
Deuteronomy 5 when citing the fourth
commandment. Only Exodus exclusively.
We'll see why I say this in a bit. Um,
but I want to answer his question here.
Where did the idea of the first day come
from?
I want to do a little bit of biblical
theology here. You might be asking,
isn't all of theology biblical theology?
And in a sense, yes. But more
specifically, biblical theology is when
we examine the process and unfolding of
the biblical narrative as it moves
toward the ultimate goal, which is God's
final revelation of the uh of the person
and work of Jesus.
So I want to do some of that here in
Genesis, which is the beginning of
redemptive history. At creation, there
were a number of ordinances.
labor.
God commanded uh man to subdue the earth
and work it. Genesis 2:15.
Marriage. Genesis 2:24-25.
Fruitfulness. Be fruitful and multiply.
The argument is typically made that the
Sabbath is not one of these because the
text nowhere states that the Sabbath was
commanded at creation. Uh the problem
that I and many others have with this is
again we don't have to utilize the
verbatim fallacy or we don't want to
utilize the verbatim fallacy. Um when we
look at the whole of scripture there are
later references in redemptive history
where we are told that the Sabbath is
rooted back in creation such as the
first giving of the law in Exodus.
But it also seemed to be Christ's
interpretation when he declares that the
Sabbath was made for man. Mark 2:27 as
Doug mentioned which would add to it uh
which would add that to the list of
labor, marriage and fruitfulness set in
the context of creation. The Sabbath was
made. He also used that word too. Did
you notice that folks? Made for man and
not the other way around. Not made for
angels,
made for man and made.
But Christ seems to agree that the
Sabbath was observed as a creation
ordinance when mankind was made. If this
is true,
which I would argue obviously it is,
then all attempts to treat the Sabbath
as unique to Israel are eliminated.
And I'm not going to get into that in
tonight's stream because the focus of
tonight is juxtaposing the first day
over and against the last day. So even
if you disagree, please track with me
and listen because this is still
applicable to the SDA church because
they do believe it's a creation
ordinance. So they have to deal with
what is being put out tonight. But I
don't think Doug realizes what Jesus
said regarding Mark 2:27. The Sabbath
was made.
And made for who? Man. Man is not
eternal.
This also poses issues with the SDA
narrative regarding it being eternal.
That in the pre-earth origin story, you
have a huge expanse of time between the
creation of Earth and the rest of the
universe. Yet, the seventh day Sabbath
was supposedly being observed prior to
the creation of Earth, even though it
was made for man who didn't exist yet.
But nevertheless, Doug, I agree. The
Sabbath was a creation ordinance made
for man and is a memorial of creation.
But not just that,
redemption and rest as well, which we
will get into uh later. But there's
something, sir, that you miss in the
narrative by not digging deep enough
that is absolutely vital in all of this.
In paradise, back back in Eden, God laid
out his intention for mankind, which
included taking dominion over the earth,
aka working. They were to be married.
They were to have children filling the
earth with other image bearsers. They
were not to work themselves ragged. They
were to rest from subduing the earth and
step away from the command to work and
worship God as a family. Essentially, uh
they were to mirror God in creation.
But Doug mentioned day six being
preparation day regarding the death,
burial, and resurrection of Christ.
Well, Genesis is prior to that obviously
in redemptive history. And we see that
the pattern of sixth day preparation was
not arbitrary. For example, notice here
Exodus 16 22-30
talks about preparation day. Notice what
it says.
On the sixth day, they gathered twice as
much bread, two omers each. And when all
the leaders of the congregation came and
told Moses, he said to them, "This is
what the Lord has commanded. Tomorrow is
a day of solemn rest, a holy Sabbath to
the Lord. Bake what you will bake and
boil what you will boil. And all that is
left over, lay aside to be kept till the
morning." So they laid it aside till the
morning as Moses commanded them. And it
did not stink, and there were no worms
in it. Moses said, "Eat it today, for
today is a Sabbath to the Lord. Today
you will not find it in the field. Six
days you shall gather it, but on the
seventh day, which is the Sabbath, there
will be none."
On the seventh day, some of the people
went out to gather, but they found none.
And the Lord said to Moses, "How long
will you refuse to keep my commandments
and my laws? See, the Lord has given you
the Sabbath. Therefore, on the sixth day
he gives you bread for two days. Remain
each of you in his place. Let no one go
out of his place on the seventh day. So
the people rested on the seventh day. So
folks, this is not arbitrary.
This is modeled after something that
came before
before the Sabbath came on the sixth
day. The Israelites were to prepare for
the Sabbath. This is modeled after God
in creation. God was teaching his people
something.
In the original creation week, God's
preparations included one, preparing a
home, which was Eden. Two, a community
in which to worship God when he created
Eve
when he created a helpmate for Adam. He
did all of this in preparation before
the day in which he then rested.
So there's a motif of this scene in
Exodus where man is modeling God which
is why he commanded it. The sixth day
being preparation day was not arbitrary.
It was on that day all necessary work
was to be done ahead of time to enable
worship on the Sabbath. But before the
fall of Adam and Eve into sin, mankind
was supposed to start his week with a
Sabbath.
And this is what the SDA church does not
catch.
After the fall, man ended the week on
the Sabbath. Notice
the days of creation are all counted
from evening to evening.
In the Western way of counting, day six
started on Friday night and finished
Saturday night.
And the wording for each day is is
interesting. So Genesis 1:15 for
example, it says there was evening and
there was morning, the first day, etc.
Adam had not experienced the evening of
day six and maybe not even the morning.
Eve for certain did not experience
anything but a short period at the end
of the sixth day. Why do I say this?
The order of events on day six were one,
the creation of land creatures. Two, the
creation of Adam.
Three, the creation of the garden. Four,
God gives instructions to man. Five, God
brings the animals before Adam to be
named, followed by a desire for him to
have his own mate. Six, then the
creation of Eve. Seven, more
instructions. And 8, ending the day with
the declaration that it was very good.
If you compare Genesis 1:29-31 with the
time span of Genesis 2 7-22, it is clear
that Eve was created toward the end of
day 6, just in time to hear God's
blessings and commands in 128-31
and prior to the ushering in of God's
rest.
This would mean that mankind's first
full day was God's Sabbath day.
Day seven of God's week as defined by
evening and morning was mankind's first
day as defined by evening and morning.
Man was not there on day 1, 2, 3, etc.
So prior to the fall, man started his
week on the Sabbath. God prepared and
fashioned man on preparation day before
they would come in and and enter his
rest and then go out and take dominion.
And since that's the case very clearly
prior to the fall, man's first day was
God's Sabbath day.
The original design was for man to start
his week in worship of God.
And then man would have followed this
pattern every seven days by starting the
week on the Sabbath on God's seventh
day.
The SDA church completely misses this.
It was not man's seventh day in the
beginning, Doug.
It was God's.
Technically, it was man's first. This is
vital, vital, vital, vital
because this then becomes tainted by
man's rebellion and sin.
When man sinned, the rest that God
provided man was symbolized in the
Sabbath, but was forfeited by by man's
disobedience and wouldn't be restored
again until the second Adam, whose
future obedience would restore all
things, meaning Jesus. So in Christ, the
day for the Sabbath is restored to its
prefall place, and man can once again
rest in God's finished work of
recreation, aka new creation and
redemption
before he then goes forth in obedience
to the Lord of subduing the earth. Which
is why Exodus 20 roots the Sabbath in
creation and Deuteronomy 5 roots it in
redemption.
Both of which also have to do with rest.
And all three are necessary in
understanding the Sabbath, creation,
rest, and redemption.
The Lord Jesus restored what man lost.
Man is now back to starting his week in
communion with God.
What came with man's rebellion was the
curse that was put on the creation. Both
Adam and his rest were cursed.
What did God say in Genesis 3 uh 17-19?
The ground Adam was to work was now
cursed. In pain he shall now eat of it.
Thorns and thistles would be produced.
More than likely talking about
exhaustion. Hence why he says he'll work
now by the sweat of his brow. So now
after the fall, man's labor and rest was
impacted by his disobedience. He broke
the creation and that impacted all
areas.
However, we also see redemption and
blessing found along with the curse in
the first proclamation of the gospel in
Genesis 3:15 where God fortells of Jesus
who would come and destroy the works of
the devil remembering or or redeeming
the creation that man broke. Notice here
what Dr. Philip Kaiser says in his book,
Sunday is the first day Sabbath. He
says, quote, Genesis 3:15 prophesies of
the coming of Jesus who would destroy
the works of the devil. Apart from the
coming of Jesus, the promise of rest in
the Sabbath would have been false and
the Sabbath would have ceased to be a
meaningful command. So God placed the
time for worship at the end of the week.
In effect, God told Adam, "So you want
to be like God? So you want to start
your week with dominion rather than
rest? I'll let you do so." In fact, to
show how miserable all dominion can be
apart from grace, I will command you to
do as I did. From this point on, you
must begin your week with dominion, and
only after long and hard striving will I
give you rest. The fact that there still
is rest is a promise that one day at the
end of this age, the promised Messiah
will bring true rest. He, as the second
Adam, will accomplish what you failed
to. So the Sabbath was no longer
celebrated at the beginning of the week,
but at the end of the week, the rest was
cursed as well as the dominion. Close
quote.
So the second Adam, Jesus Christ, did
everything the first Adam failed to do,
restoring what was lost. He obeyed
perfectly, and he is subduing the earth
perfectly as he rules and reigns, which
was a command for Adam to do. But Christ
is doing so perfectly as he rules and
reigns from heaven on his throne while
all of his enemies are being made a
foottool. 1 Corinthians 15. In the old
creation, the Sabbath day was a reminder
of man's inability.
But it also pointed to what Christ would
do by redeeming what man broke. It was a
reminder of the failure of the first
Adam, but an optimistic pointer to what
the second Adam would restore and
accomplish.
So by his redemption, Jesus made a new
creation. 2 Corinthians 5:17-19,
Romans 8:1 19-25.
And then he entered his rest after that
work was completed. Hebrews 4:10.
The first day Sabbath memorializes the
new creation work of Jesus in redemption
and is a reminder of the promise of our
consummation state as we labor for
Christ's kingdom and seek to subdue all
things. Hebrews 2.
Mankind is still commanded to subdue the
earth. But essentially sin has caused us
to fail at this.
Which is why Christ not only enters his
rest as God, but as our representative
second Adam and he labors to subdue all
things to himself on our behalf. Hebrews
1, Hebrews 2,
which is why we have the first rest or
or we have to we have to first rest in
his finished work of redemption. And by
being in him, this subduing can be
fulfilled like everything else is by and
through him. That's the key. If you
aren't resting in the finished work of
Jesus Christ, the gospel rest for the
soul, a day means absolutely nothing.
Nothing.
And this is one of the areas where the
SDA view goes completely off the rails.
Now that Jesus has come, like I rightly
recognized, it's an insult to God's
grace to continue to celebrate a seventh
day Sabbath as if he has not come.
SDAs go berserk when I say this, but
hey, let the chips fall where they may.
It's the truth. It's the equivalent of
saying the second Adam hasn't come.
Redemption hasn't happened. We're still
looking for what's act what that's
actually pointing to.
Which is why it's so interesting
whenever they appeal to Jews to try and
support this. And it's like, yeah,
they're doing the same. They're making
the same error. They reject the Messiah.
They they missed the the the substance
of uh but circumcision that was the same
way. It was a blessing in the old
covenant because it pointed to Jesus.
But once Jesus has come to get
circumcised religiously, it insults
Christ's finished work. Same thing with
the memorial of the old creation that
pointed to Jesus who would come and
redeem it. But that is in a nutshell the
foundation for the first day Sabbath
position. Man started his week with the
seventh day before the fall. his first
day being God's seventh day. After the
fall, man now ends his week with the
Sabbath until Jesus, the second Adam,
comes and restores what the first Adam
broke by redeeming the creation that
fell, making a new creation, and
restoring what man lost in the fall. The
Messiah writes the relationship of God
with his people, restores the created
order to how it was intended, starting
our week with him. The day is the
memorial,
not the substance. It points to
something. Both the seventh and the
first days pointed to Jesus. One for the
purpose of the gospel hope of redemption
and the redeeming of the creation that
fell. The other meaning the first day to
the accomplishment of that redemption in
the person and work of Jesus Christ who
re-established the pre-fall relationship
of God and man as our representative. He
entered into eternity as ahead of us.
And it is through him and him alone that
we will one day physically enter into
the eternal state with glorified bodies
to dwell in union with our maker
forever, which is the true promised
land, the eternal rest of God.
And as the biblical narrative is
unfolding, we see that the Bible or or
that the the Sabbath is rooted in rest,
redemption, and creation. Because
ultimately, like everything in
scripture, it pointed to the person and
work of Jesus.
Those of you that have been here when
we've talked through Hebrews 4 1-11,
that is exactly what the author is tying
together. We're not going to go through
that tonight. We've done so a number of
times. We're going to focus on other
areas tonight, but it's it's talking
about how Jesus is a better mediator
than Moses, who led a better Exodus, is
a better Joshua, who led a better
redemption into a better promised land,
the heavenly Mount Zion, and brought
about a better creation by redeeming the
one that fell.
What we will have in eternity is not a
return to the Garden of Eden, by the
way, like the SDA church posits. It will
be far better than that.
Y'all see why I'm constantly talking
about new creation now?
This was like a flyover. These are the
sorts of things though that Ignatius,
Tertullian, Justin Martyr, early church
fathers were recognizing from scripture.
Other generations then continued
studying and building on where those
early Christians left off. So this is
the foundation.
We will look at more uh as Doug's
presentation goes on, but this is the
starting point. Not the pope, not
Constantine or any of the other
conspiracies. It has to do with seeing
the whole biblical narrative, looking
deeper than merely the verbatim fallacy
and reading a couple verses here and
there with the great controversy as the
lens to interpret them.
Part of which is that this wasn't the
plan all along. The heavenly trio had to
hold a council after the fall where the
father had to be convinced of a plan
presented by Jesus who after three tries
convinced the father to accept his
proposed plan which was really was a
plan B.
Now this is always part of the plan. God
revealing himself more deeply to his
creation. Redeeming a people out of the
fall to demonstrate his mercy and grace.
taking their penalty upon himself in the
the greatest act of love
which also demonstrating while also
demonstrating his his justice and anger
towards sin. All of this stuff was a
revelation from God to the creation of
who he is. And as time unfolds, we see
all of that leading to the point of
Jesus Christ.
Some say, "Well, the calendar was
changed." Well, there have been a couple
of changes to the calendar. Here's an
example of one. When we went from the
Julian calendar to the Gregorian
calendar in 1582, you'll notice what
happened. They added 10 days to
compensate for the seasons. They also
put in leap years so they'd keep things
on track.
And you went to October 1 2 3 4 15. So,
did it change the calendar? Yes. Did it
change the weekly cycle? Not at all. It
went from Wednesday, Thursday, Friday,
Sabbath, Saturday. This weekly cycle has
never been changed by the calendar.
Someone wrote a letter to the U Naval
Observatory and they said, "Have there
been any changes in the calendar through
history that have affected the weekly
cycle?" They wrote back and they said
they don't know of any record of any
change to the calendar that has ever
affected the continuity of the weekly
cycle. And so when people say, "Well,
the challen we don't know what day,
Saturday, and Sunday really are anymore
because the calendar's been changed." I
think it's always interesting that uh
they never have a problem with the
calendar until they learn the Sabbath
truth. Then they say the calendar was
changed. We don't know. And if you don't
believe that, then you've got the
evidence of 15 million 16 million Jews
around the world. Uh and I could see
that some of them might be shipwrecked
on a deserted island and they lose track
of the time and say, you know, we don't
remember what day is Saturday anymore.
But for the whole nation to forget is
very unlikely.
So nothing Doug said here impacts the
first day Sabbath position.
Nothing to do with the calendar change
there. There are probably some people
out there that say that and have used
that argument. But in terms of tonight's
discussion, just for so people know, no
bearing.
The Sabbath at the end of the week was a
fall from grace and man's rest and work
being impacted by the curse put on
creation.
Doug, you already admitted that the
Sabbath was made for man. Days are a
part of creation in so far as they are a
product of the sun and the moon which
are parts of creation.
The second Adam came and restored what
the first Adam broke by redeeming the
creation that fell, recreating it and
restores the order uh man had with God
prior to sin entering which was man's
first day being God's seventh day
Sabbath, God's rest.
He evidenced here that the SDA position
does not rightly recognize that the
seventh day in creation was God's
seventh day. not man's.
And again, like I said earlier, whenever
they appeal to Jews observing the the
end of the week Sabbath, they further
evidence their unfamiliarity with new
creation because they are appealing to
individuals who reject Christ and are
still in the old creation themselves.
The Jews are still looking for the
Messiah, Doug, because they're still
observing the types and shadows that the
Messiah is the actual substance of,
which is why it's an insult to Christ to
continue in them when the substance has
come. So, just like the Jews, that's
what the SDA sign to the world every
week. But also, Doug, the Jews had other
Sabbaths. They had first day, second
day, third day, fourth day Sabbaths. The
Roman calendar has influenced your
thinking on this, sir. Here's an
example.
19889 calendar.
And notice how the Jewish year lines up
with it.
Let me get this out of the way as well.
The first column gives some examples of
first day Sabbaths that occurred in the
Jewish calendar. The feast of first
fruits, uh, first fruits, which is
resurrection day. That was never a
Sabbath day in and of itself. God
created something new when he called
resurrection day a first day Sabbath
which we are going to look at.
Which is why the Old Testament
anticipated a new day just like it
anticipated a new song, a new Exodus, a
new redemption, a new creation, etc.
Notice the numerous Sabbaths in the
Hebrew calendar. The highlighted dates
are dates that would have been Sabbaths
even if they occurred sometime in the
the middle of the week. Most of these
are laid out in Leviticus 23, which we
will be looking at some later. These
names too, like Nissan and Eer, um, are
are month names for those that don't
know. The first of every month was a new
moon Sabbath with the seventh new moon
being a special Sabbath called the feast
of trumpets. So, Numbers 28, 29,
Leviticus 23 again. But then you've got
Nissan 15, the first day of the the
feast of unleaven bread was a Sabbath.
Leviticus 23, John 19,
Nissan 16, the feast of first fruits,
which again was not a Sabbath until the
New Testament declared it to be so at
Christ's resurrection
when the Gospels, Acts, and Corinthians
refer to a first day Sabbath. And yes,
like I said, we're going to look at
that. They're not referring to a Jewish
first day Sabbath, although those did
occur in connection with other holidays.
Then you got Nissan 22, the seventh day
of the feast of unleven bread was a
Sabbath. Numbers 28,
Savon 6, Pentecost was a Sabbath, and in
this year it falls on a Sunday,
Leviticus 23:15-22.
Now, the calendar obviously doesn't end
here. This is just an example of how the
days fell. It continued with other
Sabbaths that fell on other days. Tish
one, which fell on a Monday, the feast
of trumpets. Uh, Tish 8, which fell on a
Monday. The last day, the feast of
trumpets, it was also a Sabbath. Tish
10, which was on a Wednesday, the day of
atonement. Uh, Tish 15, which fell on a
Monday. It was the first day of the
feast of tabernacles. Uh, Tish 21, which
fell on a Sunday, was a seventh of of of
tabernacles, and it was a Sabbath. And
so on. But get this, with regards to the
New Testament, a new Sabbath was born in
the Gospels. For the first time in
history, the third day of Passover,
which is sometimes referred to as first
fruits, was referred to as a Sabbath day
in each gospel. which, like I said,
we're going to be looking at later
because he's going to bring these up.
Matthew 28:1, Mark 16:2, Luke 24:1, and
John 21.
Never before had this been done before.
Work was always mandated on that day,
threshing the first fruit uh first fruit
harvest.
In each gospel account, we're going to
see that the new had come and all things
uh were beginning to be made new by
Christ. Just like Paul says in 2
Corinthians 5 and Revelation 2:15 says
there was no controversy surrounding the
church's worship being on Sunday. And
this is why Doug is going to mention
this later and it's actually the exact
opposite of what he says.
The fact that the church was universally
worshiping on the first day corporately
from the beginning and yet we see no
controversy surrounding this is evidence
that there was an understanding around
why it was being done that people
understood nothing to do with
conspiracies. The church going apostate,
the pope, Satan holding a diabolical
council meeting in outer space to set up
a false Sabbath, etc. But Doug, there
were Sabbaths that fell all sorts of
days. And you guys dismissing this is
simply as simply being festival Sabbaths
and somehow not relevant in the
discussion is evidence of why you guys
miss the substance
which was their foretelling of the
redemption of all things which would be
accomplished in a new day, the
resurrection day when the new creation
was inaugurated by Christ who was the
antiypical fulfillment of them. But
particularly like I said the feast of
first fruits and according to Hebrews
4:10 Jesus entered his rest on this day
which is why unlike God in creation who
entered his seventh day God in
redemption enters the first after the
work of redemption was accomplished.
So don't say we don't have any biblical
basis for this. You're going to see when
we look at at Leviticus because they'll
say God never called any other day holy.
Really? Then why does he call the first
day Sabbath of first fruits in Leviticus
holy? Why does he call it the eighth day
holy? A holy convocation, not to do any
any ordinary work on it.
So again, don't say we don't have any
biblical basis for any of this. We just
see a lot more fully what you guys miss
by your hyperfocusing in on small sound
bites of redemptive history, which keeps
you guys from seeing the bigger picture.
What day is the Lord's day? Now, many
Christians will say, "Well, you've got
the Sabbath day, which is what the Jews
kept, and then you've got the Lord's
day, which is what Christians teach."
And they get this from Revelation
1, I'm sorry, uh, yeah, Revelation 1:10,
where John says, "I was in the spirit on
the Lord's day, and I heard a voice
behind me like the sound of a trumpet."
And so, this is the beginning of
Revelation. They say, "See, that's the
Lord's day." But there's not a single
verse in the Bible that says that that
is referring to the Lord's day. In fact,
it's the contrary. John was imprisoned
by Rome on the aisle of Patmos where
they had mines and the prisoners were
required to work in the mines. But John
refused to work on the Sabbath day and
that is when the Lord gave him the
vision. It doesn't say anything in the
text that this is now some new different
day of worship for the children of
Israel or for the Christians. What does
the Bible say is the Lord's day? Isaiah
58:13. If you turn away your foot from
the Sabbath, from doing your pleasure on
my holy day. What day is the Lord's day?
Sabbath day. Look at this one. Exodus 6.
We just read the Ten Commandments. Sixth
day you should labor and do all your
work, but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Jews. Is that what it says?
Sabbath days is the Sabbath of the Lord.
And Jesus said, "The Son of Man is Lord
of the Sabbath." All things that were
made were made by Christ. Well, that
include when he wrote the Ten
Commandments. Yes.
Okay.
Did you notice the use of the verbatim
fallacy?
There's not a single verse that says
it's Sunday.
Uh, that's not the claim, Doug. Again,
this is arrived at by digging in deeper
than just tidbit proof texts from all
over that are just assumed to be saying
what you claim, even though it's the
great controversy theme that is
determining all of that for you. He said
there's not a single verse in the Bible
that says that the Lord's day is
referring to Sunday. In fact, it's the
contrary. So, he uses the verbatim
fallacy and wants to see a single verse
verbatim or it isn't in the Bible. Yet
immediately after saying that, he says
John worked in the coal mines on the
island of Patmos and refused to work on
Saturday, which is when he got the
vision of Revelation. Thus, the Lord's
day in Revelation 11:0 is Saturday.
Doug, where does Revelation state any of
that?
using your own standard. Show us one
verse in the Bible that says this.
Otherwise, don't hold unjust weights and
measures
that you yourself don't hold to.
You don't have a single verse in the
Bible that tells you John worked in the
coal mines and was resting on the
seventh day where he then got the vision
of the revelation on his day off. You
are appealing to extra biblical
historical sources as well as Ellen
White telling you these things, not the
Bible.
The reason Christians understand
Revelation 11:0 this way is because of
the Greek language, sir.
You'd know this if you would have
appealed to it like you did earlier with
anthropos to say it wasn't made for the
Jews. See, anthropos that means man. Ah,
okay. So, you're okay with going to the
original language there? Well, it's
because of the phrase Lord's Day cury.
John had an ample amount of ways to
communicate the Jewish Sabbath if that's
what he wanted to convey, but he used
none of them. He uses a completely
distinct and unique phrase. And the
closest thing in scripture to it,
because this is the only place it's
used, is the phrasing and syntax for the
Lord's supper in 1 Corinthians 11:20.
So, the Lord's day and the Lord's
supper. Just as the Lord's supper is a
meal that is set aside for the Lord in a
way that makes it unique, the Lord's day
is a day which is set aside for the Lord
in a way that makes it special.
And it's different from the old creation
memorial because the Greek grammar
demands it.
Adventists will be quick to try and say
it's it was Jesus's habit to meet
corporately on Saturday, and they're
correct. But he changed that habit.
The only dated records we have of his of
his meded meeting corporately after the
resurrection are on Sunday, which we're
going to be looking at later as well.
Then he appealed to Isaiah 53 and other
old other Old Testament passages.
Doug, if you understood the new creation
and first day sabotarian, the first day
sabotarian position that your pioneers
borrowed from but then twisted, you'd
realize none of what you cited is a
problem for us. It's exactly what we
would expect to see.
The Sabbath is an everlasting statute
that will not pass away until heaven and
earth pass away according to Exodus 31.
It's a sign of the everlasting covenant.
They love citing that. And Adventists
think that somehow supports their
position. And many former Adventists
will then argue not only no, it's only
perpetually binding for Israel.
But when the SDA church asserts this,
understand they did not originate this
idea.
The problem is they miss everything else
we talked about so far. like that man
prior to the fall started his week with
the Sabbath and the ending of the week
was a result of man breaking creation
and pointed to the anticipation of the
second Adam coming and restoring things.
But they love to talk about verses
that talk about the Sabbath being an
everlasting covenant, especially when
they're trying to argue that it's the
seal of God. However, this is
cherry-picking
because the other two signs of the
Mosaic covenant, circumcision and
Passover, are also said to be forever,
but they're not going to be observed in
heaven,
as that isn't what the author meant by
saying that they are forever.
But you don't hear the SDA church, you
know, claiming the angels were getting
circumcised in heaven prior to the
creation of the earth, do you?
Yet they'll appeal to these statements
about the Sabbath being perpetual to
then say, "So that proves it was being
observed in heaven before the earth was
created and it will be into heaven
according to Isaiah 66." No, these
ordinances are perpetual in that in the
new covenant they change into new
covenant forms.
The substance being the same, but the
form is is what's different.
Circumcision into baptism, Colossians 2,
Passover into the Lord's Supper, and
then the seventh day Sabbath into the
first day Sabbath.
Remember, we already see the form of the
Sabbath change with the fall of man. We
then see the form change in the second
giving of the law where Deuteronomy 5
says the Sabbath was rooted in
redemption, not creation like in Exodus.
That is what's called a form change. It
is a change in the ceremonial form of
the command. The substance remains the
same while the ceremonial form changes.
So yes, Adventists, the form of the
fourth commandment can indeed change. It
has changed
and the way of observing it in the new
creation is not identical to that of the
old creation.
But if Doug appealed to Kuryak Himera in
this instance like he did Anthropos,
he'd have to deal with this this issue
which their scholars have tried. And
well, you can go check those things out
for yourself. There's all sorts of
ministry magazine. They've got all sorts
of of ideas they typically just want to
appeal to. Well, Jesus said that he's
Lord of the Sabbath, and that has to be
Saturday. So, therefore, curyaki himera
has to mean uh Saturday's the Lord's
day. It's like, well, no, you're not
dealing with the grammar like at all.
Notice how the early church was not at
all ignorant of the new creation and the
antityypical fulfillment that the first
day plays in redemption. Okay?
in Ignatius's uh epistle to the
Magnesians. We've looked at this before,
a disciple of John the Apostle who
penned the Revelation
since Doug is going to appeal to extra
biblical source materials. You know,
John was working in the coal mines.
Okay, we're going to do the same thing.
Remember that Ellen White quote earlier,
too.
Ignatius, disciple of John the Apostle,
who penned the revelation,
speaking of the Lord's day, he says,
quote,
"Be not deceived with strange doctrines,
nor with old fables which are
unprofitable.
For if we still live according to the
Jewish law, we acknowledge that we have
not received grace.
If therefore those who were brought up
in the ancient order of things, talking
about the Jews, have come to the
possession of a new hope, no longer
observing the Sabbath, talking about the
Jewish Sabbath, but living in the
observance of the Lord's day, on which
also our life has sprang up again by him
and by his death, let every friend of
Christ keep the Lord's day as a
festival, the resurrection day, the
queen and chief of all days of the week.
It is absurd to speak of Jesus Christ
with the tongue and to cherish in the
mind a Judaism which has now come to an
end. For where there is Christianity,
there cannot be Judaism. Close quote.
These are the sorts of people that Doug
and the SDA church will point to to say,
"See, they hated Jews." When no, they
hated Judaizing, which is an insult to
the Lord Jesus. It is a rejection of the
substance of the types and shadows which
is why they still embrace these things
and hold on to them because of their
rejection of Messiah.
Jesus is the fulfillment of all the
types and shadows and to still observe
them is an insult to God by denying that
the substance of those things has come.
But Ignatius writing in the second
century he refers to the Lord's day as
Sunday using the phrase in Revelation
1:10. Doug, you appealed to extra
biblical sources for John being a worker
in the coal mines. So, here we are doing
the same. Disciple of the apostle
disagrees with you.
Which is why some SDAs will make the
absurd claim that Ignatius was a
heretic. Absolutely ridiculous.
But does that sound like the early
church viewed the first day as just any
other day?
They weren't keeping Sunday, only a
recreational worship day according to
Ellen. Ignatius says it's the the queen
and chief of days and every friend of
Christ should keep it. Yes, keep that
day. Early Christians were not against
new covenant daykeeping.
Which is why origin
writing at the beginning of the 3rd
century in his homalies 23 on numbers uh
chapter 4 he says this
on Sunday none of the actions of the
world should be done. If then you
abstain from all the works of this world
and keep yourselves free for spiritual
things, go to church, listen to the
readings and divine homalies, meditate
on heavenly things. Close quote.
No, no. Early Christians all believed
Sunday is just a normal working day,
right?
Sunday was just a recreational and
Saturday was viewed as as sacred. No.
Ellen just didn't know what the heck she
was talking about. or the Oregon. Well,
the the origin wasn't really a Christian
because he doesn't look identical to how
I look. Yeah, I'm aware that origin held
to some some wacky beliefs in some
areas, but we're we're examining history
here. History doesn't care about your
opinions.
Homalies are sermons. So, this was
origin preaching on Numbers 4 and making
application to the present day believer.
Now, whether the SDA church agrees with
him or not is irrelevant to the fact
that again, this is history. Long before
Constantine, long before Council of
Leadyia, long before Pope Sylvester 1
and all the other conspiracies they try
and claim gave Sunday its sabbatical
character, origin says one should
abstain from all worldly work and keep
yourself free for spiritual things such
as going to church, listening to
readings and sermons to meditate on
heavenly things, aka it's a Sabbath.
That doesn't sound like an ordinary
working day to me.
Clement of Alexandria
in the Stramata book two. He writes
about all sorts of stuff in this book.
But notice what he says about the Lord's
day.
Quote, "For the highest achievement for
one who has had trial of it afterwards
to abstain. For what great thing is it
if a man restrains himself in what he
knows not? He in fulfillment of the
precept according to the gospel keeps
the Lord's day when he abandons an evil
disposition and assumes that of the
Gnostic glorifying the Lord's
resurrection in himself.
So he's writing against Gnostic heretics
here. But this shows that the early
Eastern Christians believe the gospel
way of keeping the fourth commandment is
on the Lord's day and that the Lord's
day is the day Christ rose from the
dead. The first day, this is 190 AD.
almost 200 I guess technically. And
again, it shows early Christians were
not against new covenant daykeeping. And
guess what Adventists? He even advocates
for the ten commandments in book two
specifically with regards to the fifth
commandment to obey your parents, which
is why he argues against the
aestheticism of his day and those who
were opposed to marriage.
Nevertheless, Cyprien, Bishop of
Carthage,
in his epistle 58, roughly 250 AD,
quote, the eighth day, that is the first
day after the Sabbath and the Lord's
day. Close quote.
This again destroys the SDA historical
revisionism where they claim that Pope
Sylvester 1 gave the imposing title of
Lord's Day to Sunday like JN Andrews in
his book, The History of the Sabbath,
said.
It also further demonstrates that the
early church had the understanding that
the first day was called the eighth day.
And there's a reason for that. We're not
getting into the eighth day tonight.
We're going to save that for an entirely
different stream.
But in the Old Testament, you have
significance of of the eighth day um
being a new day that the Lord would make
for telling of the resurrection and the
new creation etc.
Now notice what Yia says.
4th century.
This is his commentary on Psalm 92,
which is a psalm for the Sabbath day.
Quote, "The word talking about Christ by
the new covenant translated and
transferred the feast of the Sabbath to
the morning light and gave to us the
image of the true rest, the day of
salvation, the Lord's day,
the first of the light on which the
Savior of the world, after all his
labors among men, obtained the victory
over death, and passed the portals of
heaven, having achieved a work superior
to the six days creation on on this day
and received the divine Sabbath and
blessed rest. When the Father said to
him, "Sit at my right hand until I make
all of your enemies your foottool." On
that day, which is the first of light
and of the true Son, we also assemble
after an interval of six days and
celebrate holy and spiritual Sabbaths.
No. No. According to Ellen White, Sunday
was just a standard working day in the
early church. They still kept and
observed the sacredness of Saturday
supposedly.
Yeah. No.
Like originius
speaks of the Lord's day, the new day
God has made by Christ resurrecting and
accomplishing the redemption of the
creation that fell. And then we
Christians keep that day and celebrate
holy and spiritual Sabbaths.
That isn't a normal run-of-the-mill same
old same old day. Friend, Ellen was
wrong. Or you have to say, "Well, yeius
wasn't a Christian." Oh man, we're we're
just throwing them all out. Like, okay.
And for those who've heard me walk
through Hebrews 4 1-11,
you can see it's not my private
interpretation. This isn't's private
interpretation either.
But you're going to notice he says the
same thing I've laid out before. The
same thing Thomas Watson did that we
looked at a couple weeks ago. The same
thing John Owens said that we looked at.
The Christian church has understood this
for a long time.
It isn't some private interpretation
under the tree, Holy Spirit and me type
thing.
God in creation did a mighty work,
accomplished that miraculous work, and
entered his rest the seventh day, man's
first day.
But God in redemption did a mira a
mighty miraculous work by redeeming that
creation that fell into sin. Recreated
it, accomplished that work, but entered
his rest not the seventh day but the
first day, the day when Jesus walked out
of the tomb.
Finally, let's look here at Athanasius.
Quote, "The Jewish Sabbath was the end
of the first creation.
The Lord's day was the beginning of the
second in which he renewed and restored
the old in the same way as he prescribed
that they should formerly observe the
Sabbath as a memorial of the end of the
first things. So we honor the Lord's day
as being the memorial of the new
creation. Close quote.
Nothing to do with the Pope, nothing to
do with conspiracy theories. New
creation.
Some people just seed these individuals
to the Roman Catholic Church and they'll
say, "Oh, that's I don't care. I I don't
I don't." And not just that, but even if
that's the case, so what? That's genetic
fallacy. I don't care if just because
someone else says it doesn't mean it's
wrong by virtue of the person saying it.
But nevertheless,
recognizing both old and new creation is
the key. Paul plainly tells us we're in
the new creation presently by virtue of
stating that when a person's born again,
they're made a new creature or it'll say
creation in some translations. 2
Corinthians 5:17.
That means more than just behavior
modification. Now, I could go on and on
as that was just a sampling, but Doug,
neither scripture, meaning the grammar
of Revelation 11:0
on your guys' side of this topic. The
text doesn't say anything about John
working in the coal mines and the vision
coming to him on the seventh day Sabbath
when he was resting from work. Yet you
want to hold others to a standard that
you yourself aren't utilizing. That's
called unjust weights and measures and
hypocrisy. The fact is the conclusion is
arrived at from the Greek grammar and
syntax as Greek grimarians have pointed
out for centuries. Not me just saying
that
the Lord's supper is the closest thing
that we have in scripture to something
identical because the phrase kuryakimera
is unique to this verse and only appears
here. Furthermore, all of Christian
history is on our side supporting this
understanding. And I know that most of
you guys don't care about that cuz
tradition is not inspired. So just
outright dismiss it. Toss it in the can.
Who cares? But it doesn't change the
facts. Ellen White was flatout wrong
that all Christians kept the seventh day
Sabbath in the first centuries plural
centuries.
No, they didn't. Ignatius, Origin,
Cyprien, Justin and Martyr, Athanasius,
Tertullian, and literally every other
gift God gave to the church. Those
people weren't Christians. Apparently,
the men involved in the preservation of
the biblical text,
a disciple of John the Apostle. It's
like, all right, but a bunch of
anti-trinitarian,
gospel-denying heretics of the 19th
century who resurrected all sorts of
ancient heresies and claimed to be
restoring the church that went totally
apostate contrary to God promising to
preserve it. They were the true
Christians. Okay, got it.
So, if the Sabbath is the Lord's day,
why do so many people worship on Sunday?
You know, this was in our uh scripture
reading. Jesus said, "All too well you
reject the commandment of God that you
may keep your tradition. Sunday keeping
is not based on scripture. It is based
on a tradition." I'm going to prove it
to you from the Bible as we go on here
and from history. Uh some of you have
heard this interesting story from
history where I think it was Zorn
Nicholas. He looked out of his palace
walls one day and he noticed that this
guard had always been standing at this
obscure place on the wall. There's no
gate. There was no door. And one day he
was walking in the garden. He went up to
the garden. He said, "Why exactly are
you standing here?" Well, the guard was
very nervous and he said, "Well, I have
orders to stand here, your majesty."
And he said, "Do you know why?" He said,
"No, we've just always had someone here
24 hours a day." So he went to the
captain. Alzar was getting very curious
and he said, "Why do we always have a
soldier standing at that particular
remote spot in the garden? There's
nothing there." And he said, "Well,
we've it's just been a standing order
for years. We've always had 24 hours a
day a guard is to be stationed there.
It's been mandated. It's in the
archives."
So Lazar went to look at the archives to
try and find out why is there a soldier
there? in the archives it said a hundred
years earlier Katherine the Great was
entertaining guests one of her guests
came a dignitary from another country
and gave her a gift of an exotic rose
bush
they planted the rose bush and she said
I don't want this to be trampled have a
guard guard my rose bush well the rose
bush died five years after they planted
it
but at that point they were in the habit
of guarding that spot and so for a
hundred years a guard was standing there
without questioning why he was standing
there. It was a tradition
and there are still traditions that
Christians guard that there is no rhyme
or reason for except that it's a
tradition. There's no biblical reason
for it.
So Doug just bore a false witness and
lied about Christians violating the
entirety of the law by doing so. No
rhyme or reason for worship on the first
day. Is that what we've seen thus far?
We haven't even gotten into the other
key areas like we're going to shortly.
Sorry, I know I'm getting,
Doug. You don't even understand new
creation.
You haven't mentioned it a single time
thus far. Yet, you claim it's all
tradition. There's not a shred of
biblical evidence for it. You haven't
even meaningfully engaged yet. You just
prattled off a bunch of proof texts and
made a bunch of assertions.
assumed great controversy world details
and misrepresented the position. Sir, I
challenge you to a publicly moderated
debate on this subject. Not that I think
you'll take me up on it, but either way,
I'll fly out to California. We can do it
there at your church, Granite Bay. You
get homefield advantage. Let's see who
does and doesn't have scripture to
support their claims. Okay?
And what we'll actually do is walk
through the passages that we cite,
showing that we contextually know what
it is that we're citing to make sure
we're not just regurgitating a long list
of recycled proof texts with good ortor
skills to wow an audience. How's that
sound?
Because your silly analogy of a guard
standing post as a tradition we
inherited
and not having any clue why he does it
is completely irrelevant to me and
anyone else down through Christian
history that understood the subject and
has studied it deeply. Is that what
Ignatius said? Is that what Origin said?
Is that what Cyprien said? Is that what
I've said? It's just all tradition. And
well, I don't even know why I do this
folks. Every time Adventists claim this,
they are either ignorant or bearing
false witness,
evidencing that no, they don't care
about the Ten Commandments. They're not
the commandmentkeeping church. This is
why constantly say violating the ninth
commandment is hardcoded into this
system.
They parrot Mrs. whites bearing false
witness about Christians and why we
worship the first day, attributing it to
Satan,
saying there's no biblical reason for
such.
This lie is then attributed to God since
it's coming through Mrs. White.
Supposedly,
it came from Satan.
Resurrection day, Jesus fulfilling the
promises. God talking about a new day in
the Psalm. Like, it's all about creation
and redemption. Still the substance is
still the same. It came from Satan.
Okay.
No, it isn't just a tradition with no
rhyme or reason. Laughable to say when
you can't even articulate the serious
theological position, but swing at
lowhanging fruit instead. Like he's
about to do with a broad brush here uh
and and broadbrush all of Christianity
as a whole.
So, some of the other um scriptures have
explained this. Ezekiel 22:26 and verse
31, "Her priests have violated my law
and profaneed my holy things. They put
no difference between the profane and
the holy. They have hid their eyes from
my Sabbaths,
and I am profaneed among them.
Therefore, I have poured out my
indignation on them." You know, one of
the reasons I was convinced of the
Sabbath truth is because after I first
learned these things, I went to my
pastors. I used to go to church on
Sunday. I was so into Christianity. I
was going to several different churches.
One church said we'd have a Wednesday
night Bible study. I'd be there. Then I
go to another denomination. I'd be at
their service. Another one would have a
special early morning service. I went
there. I was going to four or five
different churches, studying with all
these Christian groups in Southern
California. I was just hungry. I
couldn't get enough. But when I learned
the Sabbath truth, I'd ask the different
pastors. I'd say, "So, why do we go to
church on Sunday?"
And if you ask 10 different pastors, you
would get 11 different answers.
One would say, these are just a few
examples.
Doug, we're no longer under the Ten
Commandments.
Uh, we're now under grace. I said,
"Well, what does that mean? Does that
mean that we don't need to keep the Ten
Commandments?" They said, "Well, we're
not under the law." I said, "Well, wait.
Let me help me understand that. Is it
okay now to kill? Well, no. Steal? No.
Lie? No. Commit adultery? No. What they
really meant is there's one commandment
you're not supposed to remember anymore.
That's the Sabbath. I said, but isn't
that the one that says remember?
So that didn't make sense. And so I
talked to another one. He said, um,
because of the resurrection, Jesus rose
on the first day of the week and so it
is the new Christian Sabbath. I said,
that sounds beautiful. Said, where is
the scripture that tells us that? Well,
there is no specific scripture, but
we've got a long-standing tradition as
though there's some value in that. And
then I I had another friend. He was the
most creative. And he said, "Doug, back
in the days of Joshua, you remember
Joshua prayed and the sun stood still.
Saturday turned into Sunday back then."
And I said, "Well, that's interesting."
I said, "Except why did they continue to
keep it on the seventh day for another
1500 years after that?" and he couldn't
answer that. And they were all giving me
differences. They didn't agree with each
other. I said, "Something's wrong." They
are hiding their eyes
from a very obvious truth because they
have counted the cost of what will what
will it mean if I take a stand for this
biblical truth. I'll lose my
congregation. I'll be very unpopular. I
know pastors that have taken a stand and
it cost them. I know some pastors took a
stand for the truth and the majority of
the church followed them in the Sabbath
truth and so it's always better.
No, we aren't hiding our eyes to the
Sabbath truth, Doug.
Neither are pastors like mine or any
other first day sabotarian.
If anything, affirming the first day
Sabbath costs you because then you get
both seventh day sabotarians like you
misrepresenting us and making conspiracy
claims that we're tools of Satan. Then
on the other hand, we get Christians
that reject Sunday as being any sort of
significant day. And they're mad that we
think it should be kept by Christians.
What we have a problem with is your
fiction that the seventh day Sabbath is
the seal of God,
that a person's salvation hinges on it,
that Sunday will be the mark of the
beast eventually, and so on.
We also have a problem with you
memorializing the broken creation that
Adam plunged into sin, not recognizing
that man prior to the fall started his
week with the Sabbath, and that Jesus,
the substance of the Sabbath, came and
restored what man broke and brought
about a new creation, which is
memorialized on the day he accomplished
it, the first day.
He mentioned when somebody says, "We
worship on the first day because of the
resurrection." Doug, this is a summation
statement. It should include a therefore
before it.
Meaning after all that we worship on the
first day because of the resurrection.
It's because of the resurrection
or it's because the resurrection is the
day in which the new creation was
inaugurated by virtue of Christ
accomplishing the work he came to do.
After that completed work, it was time
for him to return to his rightful abode,
entering his rest by sitting down on his
throne as a priest king. This is what
Ucius was referring to earlier. Picking
that up from the psalm as well as
Hebrews 4
to rule and reign over all things as
king of kings and lord of lords, reaping
the fruits of his labors of the work of
redemption.
In conjunction with what I talked about
earlier, the Sabbath in redemption,
folks, looks like this.
The first day memorializes redemption
being accomplished.
That happened at the resurrection. The
new creation was ushered in by virtue of
Jesus who redeemed that postfall
creation that fell into sin,
accomplished that work successfully and
entered his rest, God's rest ahead of
us. And the day he entered his rest
serves as a memorial that points us to
that what we look forward to.
Man breaks the creation, plunges it into
sin.
Remember, prefall it was God's seventh
day, not man's.
Based on evening to evening,
it was man's first.
Man was fashioned and prepared on the on
on day six, preparation day, to then
enter God's rest, holy communion, and
fellowship with God.
After the fall, the promise of
redemption is then given in Genesis 3:15
with redemptive history leading to the
incarnation where God himself enters the
broken creation, redeems it, and
restores man to his right relationship
with God.
He accomplished that work successfully
and is now making all things new
presently. Revelation 21:5
on the pathway to the second coming
where he will return to defeat the last
enemy, which is death. 1 Corinthians 15.
And then we'll cast that into the lake
of fire, which will usher us into being
resurrected in glorified bodies, and we
will finally physically enter into
eternity with God.
That's the consummation of all things.
That is what the Sabbath is about. Not
the SDA twisting and microscoping in on
one aspect of redemptive history and
then making that the substance while
attributing everything to some grand
conspiracy by Satan to deceive people.
and he instituted Sunday as a trick and
a deception and so on. Both in the old
and new creation, the memorial
ultimately pointed to the same thing.
The rest that remains for us to enter
into
one will enter into there by believing
the gospel.
That's what the author in Hebrews 4 is
imploring. Israel heard the good news.
They had it preached to them, but they
didn't enter.
They were observing a day.
The day is a memorial, not the substance
like the SDA church makes it.
Not that it points to the eternal rest
of entering into eternity with God,
but that in in eternity there's going to
be a seven-day cycle and the seventh day
Sabbath will be observed.
completely missing the point. It's not a
return to Eden. Mount Zion is better.
Eden was a starting point in the plan of
God to enter into creation himself in
the person of Christ, redeeming a
people, demonstrating his justice
towards sin, his grace and and and love
in saving a people,
fix what man broke, and then bring
himself ultimately glory out of all of
that. That was always the plan, not a
plan B afterthought like Ellen portrays
in the great controversy.
But Doug and SDA present this this claim
as though it said because Jesus
resurrected Sunday, well now we worship
on that day and that's it. When in
reality, it's way more theologically
rich than that.
We see the Sabbath all throughout
redemptive history leading and pointing
us to Jesus where the story then
climaxes to the person and work of God
coming in the flesh to restore
everything man broke ushering us back
into fellowship and union with God.
Rest for the soul in the gospel and
eventually rest for the body when we
receive glorification which will be a
better state than Adam and Eve were in.
But because he went to some pastors down
the street and asked them about the
Sabbath and they didn't have a strong
understanding in this area, that means
Christians as a whole have no basis.
Doug, I've talked with Adventist
pastors, lots of them, and they all
present Adventism differently with none
of them agreeing on what it means to
fundamentally be an Adventist.
So that must mean that no Adventists
know or have a baseline for what it
means to be an Adventist, right?
He doesn't even know the serious
theological arguments because he didn't
actually consult any sort of theologian
that has spent time executing scripture
regarding the Sabbath like a Nicholas
Bound or a John Owen
shoot any of the ancient
just read their homalies. They're
expounding upon upon scripture and
they're bringing this out. It's like
they have this weird aversion to to
church fathers around like icky or just
like oh they don't look identical to how
I am.
Okay, you can still un you can still
look at this and say historically that's
what people were saying. This is long
before Constantine.
They're not just saying, "Oh, just
because of the resurrection."
Instead, he uses lowhanging fruit
examples of well-meaning Christians who
just aren't as learned on on this and
then broad brushes. Classic Doug
Bachelor move.
Doug, you should have consulted
theologians and theological works.
Just because you found some pastors
that, believe it or not, are not all-
knowing
and didn't have a sufficient answer for
you doesn't mean that it's not out
there. For too long, Protestantism just
took this for granted and didn't have a
strong apologetic or teaching around
this subject. But it's been there. The
understanding was around long before
SDAs were around.
I mean, we just look to individuals back
to the second century.
It's been discussed theologically for
almost 2,000 years.
I mean, read the Puritans that your
pioneers borrowed from, but then
twisted.
This idea that you have to search far
and wide, and he seem he tries to
portray it like this to find an answer.
Doug, you have a computer.
Get on your computer. Let's hear you
respond to the actual theological
arguments, not just lowhanging fruit.
Pointing to people who just weren't
equipped on the subject is not an
argument.
If I utilize that standard against
Adventism, mercy.
I could make Adventism look horrible.
Just ask 10 different Adventists about
the sanctuary, you'll get 12 different
answers, Doug. Well, then again, you
actually may get multiple people saying
it's confusing, so maybe it wouldn't be
12 different answers.
But we could then by Doug's standard say
the SDA church is confused and they have
they they don't even know what they
believe about the sanctuary teaching. No
one does.
And guess what they would do? Send us to
their scholars. Which means I rest my
case. Adventists can say what they want
about this platform that I misrepresent
them. I'm clueless. Yada yada. But I
actually interact with their scholastic
materials and official source materials.
Not lowhanging fruit. Not Joe Schmo SDA
down the block. No, Ministry magazine,
the Adventist Theological Society
papers, BARRI articles, Ellen White
writings, writings from the pioneers,
but individuals like Doug don't actually
have to do that. They get to rattle off
their script and their talking points
and proof texts, make claims about
others, but not actually read the
materials of those that they criticize
and actually learn what they believe
because it's a closed system. He can
just give these sorts of talks to a room
full of SDAs that just Oh yeah, brother.
Oh yeah. And they just eat it up and it
just keeps the the fuel in the machine.
But also, Doug, your friend Ted Wilson
at his annual council speech both this
year and last year and in a new video
that was uploaded today that we're going
to respond to told us to be on the
lookout for anyone not utilizing the
historical grammatical method of
interpretation. He even warned of the
same thing at the hold the line
conference that you had at your own
church. You didn't utilize the HGM. You
just rattled off proof text like you did
earlier. So I guess we need to keep an
eye out for you.
Okay. So now he's going to begin
addressing all of the first day passages
starting with Matthew 28. So, what we're
going to do now, um, if we want to know
why why would any Christian keep Sunday
instead of the Sabbath, the first day
instead of the seventh, um, we're going
to look at every reference to Sunday,
except you realize the word Sunday does
not appear in the New Testament.
Sometimes you'll hear the word sunundry
if you're reading the King James.
Sunundry is not Sunday. Sunday means
different. God in various times and
sunundry manners spoke to the prophets
in time past. That means different
manners.
Um so if you look at every reference to
the first day of the week, which is what
we commonly refer to as Sunday,
you might find if there's a change,
there's eight references in the New
Testament. Now, nobody's going to argue
the Old Testament because it's very
clear it's a seventh day there. So,
we're going to take them one by one.
Does that sound fair? And we'll look at
them and see what the Bible says. Look
at the first four references are simply
historical. They are talking about the
time of the resurrection. Matthew 28:1
in the end of the Sabbath. Uh my friend
Harold Camping, I say that a little bit
sarcastically. I apologize. Harold
Camping was the founder of Family Radio,
good radio station. I listen to them.
But he used to answer Bible questions
and he would always when people asked
about the Sabbath, he would go to this
verse. He say, "See what it says right
there? The end of the Sabbath. That
means the Sabbath is now over. You don't
need to keep the Sabbath anymore. I
said, "That's not what it's saying. It's
saying that that week after the
crucifixion, after the Sabbath was over,
it's saying that they came early in the
morning on the first day of the week."
You tried to build a whole doctrine. I
told you there's 11 different answers.
If you ask 10 different pastors a reason
why as it began towards the first day of
the week. Now, is that a new command to
keep the first day? No. Do you find
built into that anything that says now
we have a new Sabbath day? It's on the
first day. No, it's a simple historical
record. Now, did was it important that
Jesus rose on the first day of the week?
Absolutely.
Does that make it a new Sabbath? Was
there anything wrong with the seventh
day where God had to now change it? No.
Was the seventh day Sabbath chosen
before or after sin?
Before sin. It's part of God's perfect
plan. There's nothing wrong with it. Did
God do important things on Thursday?
Was the Lord's supper important? That's
Thursday. Does it make it a new Sabbath?
How important is the crucifixion?
What day of the week was that? Friday.
Is that a new Sabbath? Not for us. It is
for the Muslims.
So, the Lord does different things, but
he didn't command us to keep any other
day than the first day. That would be
like saying, "I made a mistake with the
seventh day. Um, now it's the first.
So, he had a little slip of the tongue
there. He uh he mistakenly said, "My
position," which I was like when I first
heard this, "Oh, Doug, you may have
finally gotten it." But Harold Camping,
seriously,
false dates setter, false prophet,
Harold Camping. That's an exed you're
going to refer to. Okay. So, notice he
asks, "Was the seventh day chosen before
or after sin?"
Doug, it wasn't man's seventh day before
the fall. It was God's.
It was man's first day based on the
evening to evening cycle.
And man would have started his week with
the Sabbath every week until he broke
the creation trying to be his own God.
And his rest was cursed along with the
work. But God was merciful in promising
the Messiah who would come and destroy
the works of the devil, restoring what
was lost, redeeming creation, bringing
man back into his pre-fall conditions.
That is what's underway currently. While
he makes all of his enemies a foottool,
the first day Sabbath has been restored,
which points us to the completed work of
redemption in Christ and ultimately
God's rest, which is the final
destination.
You guys memorialize the old fallen
creation as if the Messiah hasn't come.
But because you don't understand new
creation, you can't see it.
It wasn't just because important things
took place that day. And then you could
just appeal to important things on any
day. And
wow,
it isn't the same as the Lord's supper
and the crucifixion. Yes, all of those
are important, but it isn't just because
it's important. The resurrection was the
turning point of the new creation, not
the Lord's supper, not the crucifixion.
This just evidences your weak theology
around the resurrection.
This wasn't just an an important thing.
It was a cataclysmic universe altering
thing.
You also again didn't utilize the HGM at
all to arrive at your conclusion. Again,
Ted Wilson warned to be on the lookout
for anyone who isn't utilizing the
historical grammatical method.
You just breezed over the text on a
flawed foundation to show why it can't
be the case
that this has anything to do with the
church gathering corporately on the
first day of worship. You didn't even
bother to cite the entire paricopy and
walk through the text bringing out the
author's intended meaning, understanding
what the original audience would have,
which is what the HGM is all about.
Had you done so, you would have realized
why this passage is far more complicated
than you make it sound.
In fact,
you guys love Martin Luther. I've heard
you cite him on his views regarding the
state of the dead, which he shifted on
later in his life, by the way, due to
the biblical text.
Well, let's look at his translation of
this verse and then the mechanics around
why he arrived at the conclusion that he
did.
Luther was utilizing the Texas receptus
manuscript line which is what the King
James was translated from that the
SDAs's love. How does he translate it as
first day Sabbath
quote Luther's translation now in the
evening of the Sabbath which began in
the morning of the first semity of
Sabbaths
came Mary Magdalene and the other Mary
to see the sephiler.
So Luther's 1545 translation picks up on
the Greek grammar and the fact that the
word for Sabbath and dawn of the first
day of the week like you see in the ESV
are the exact same word.
You can see the Greek the literal
rendering of it out and then how the ESV
in this case renders it.
Same identical word for both.
same identical word for Sabbath is used
twice in the sentence in the same
context using the same grammar.
It is arbitrary to then translate the
first instance as Sabbath and the second
one as first day of the week.
Listen to why Dr. Kaiser thinks that the
most natural uh rendering of the text is
first day Sabbath like Luther Basa Miles
Cloverdale and a number of other
translators through the years.
He says, quote, first, so he's going to
give three reasons why he believes this
is how it should be translated.
First, this was the way Jews translated
the Hebrew for the Sabbath into Greek.
For those who think that the genative,
that's just the verb or no, that's no,
sorry, ignore me. For those who think
that the genative should be translated
with an of, it should be noted that the
usual case for Sabbath is the genative
since its original meaning was of rest.
So meaning a day of rest.
Thus the Greek translation, not the
Hebrew, the Greek translation of Exodus
20 is simply the Sabbath.
And Matthew 28:1 is simply and after the
Sabbath. Likewise, the singular day
Sabbath is usually in the plural. This
can be seen by even a casual glance
through a Greek concordance.
Why does the translation have to change
when the form is the same for both words
in Matthew 28:1?
While it is possible to paraphrase
Sabbath as weak, there's only one
biblical text where such a paraphrase
would be helpful, which is Luke 18:12.
And that is simply because I fast twice
since the Sabbath would be way too
wooden for an English translation. Close
quote. So what he is saying is that it
is arbitrary to translate the same word
in the same sentence two different ways
when they're being used in the identical
context
which would mean that the most natural
rendering of the text would be first day
Sabbath. He continues
second the grammar calls for it. Keep in
mind that the word first is in the
feminine singular accusative whereas
Sabbath is neuter plural genative just
as in the Greek form not the Hebrew of
the fourth commandment. Therefore it is
clear that first does not modify Sabbath
but rather it modifies the implied word
day.
This construction occurs several times
in the Septuagen. That's the Greek
translation of the Hebrew Old Testament.
Therefore, it is grammatically
impossible to translate it as one of the
Sabbaths. It has to be first day
Sabbath. Third, the ancient translations
translated as first day Sabbath. A
listing of other occurrences of first
day Sabbath in the New Testament helps
to make the previous points clear. Close
quote.
So that first part he's responding to
those Greek grammarians that would claim
that the word first is modifying the
word Sabbath. So it should be more
accurately translated as one of the
Sabbaths which is how some people have
translated.
Dr. Kaiser on the other hand argues that
the word day is implied in the phrase
Sabbath
which can be seen in the Greek
translation of the Old Testament the
Septuent specifically in Exodus 20 which
shows that it must be first day Sabbath
not simply one of the Sabbaths.
Furthermore the ancient translations of
the biblical text like the Ethiopic
translation also translated as such.
Then on top of that we're going to look
at some of these other ones. the other
texts that have the same Greek
construction,
they all do the same thing.
So, the purpose in saying this is to not
appear like I'm some Greek grimarian.
I'm not. But I've tried digging into
both sides of the discussion.
So, I can say with confidence that it is
a lot more complicated than Doug made it
out to be, just breezing over the text,
not actually examining why theologians
down through the centuries have appealed
to this text the way they have. Oh, but
there's no rhyme or reason for it. Just
a silly claim, especially considering he
appealed to Greek regarding the Sabbath
being made for man earlier, anthropos,
which I agree. We'll do that same thing
here as well. And with Lord's Day in
Revelation 110, I had a friend a few
weeks ago. He sent me a response from an
Adventist to first day Sabbath being in
the Greek, but essentially getting lost
in translation to some degree. The guy
claimed no serious theologian or
translator ever translated it this way.
Oh, so Martin Luther, Miles Coverdale,
Theodore Beasa, the modern King James,
the Vulgate, the Clementine Vulgate, and
and numerous other translations.
All the individuals involved in those
works are not serious translators. Okay,
got it.
Now, let's actually read Matthew 28 1-10
and look at and look at the reason this
text is cited by Christians historically
with regards to the first day being
significant because Doug didn't even
address it.
It says, "Now after the Sabbath, toward
the dawn of the first day of the week,
Mary Magdalene and the other Mary went
to see the tomb. And behold, there was a
great earthquake, for an angel of the
Lord descended from heaven and came and
rolled back the stone and sat on it. His
appearance was like lightning, and his
clothing white as snow. And for fear of
him, the guards trembled and became like
dead men. But the angel said to the
woman, "Do not be afraid, for I know
what you seek, or I yeah, I know what
you seek, Jesus, who was crucified. He
is not here, for he has risen."
As he said, come see the place where he
lay. Then go quickly and tell his
disciples that he had risen from the
dead. And behold, he is going before you
to Galilee. There you will see him. See,
I have told you." So they departed
quickly from the tomb with fear and
great joy and ran to tell his disciples.
And behold, Jesus met them and said,
"Greetings." And they came up and took
hold of his feet and worshiped him. Then
Jesus said to them, "Do not be afraid.
Go and tell my brothers to go to
Galilee, and there they will see me.
Close the reading of God's holy word.
Now, we looked at this a couple weeks
ago. What do we see? Well, actually, let
me bring that back up.
The substance of everything the church
does all taking place on the first day
Sabbath.
Not just the first day Sabbath, the
first first day Sabbath in the new
creation.
Both Marys heard the gospel from the
messenger, an angel, someone bringing
the gospel message. They were told the
good news. He is risen. They believe
that message and then go to meet Jesus.
We're told he met with them in verse 9.
The word of God, which is what Jesus's
words are, is then spoken over them.
Upon doing so, they cling to him and
worship him.
After doing so, they're then sent out by
Christ to take the gospel to others.
This is exactly what the substance of
the church
gathering on the first day is.
We leave our place of dwelling. We meet
with Jesus who is present in a special
way. We worship him. The word of God has
spoken over us. washing us in it. We
believe it. We cling to him, partake of
him at his table in the supper, and then
we're sent out into the world to take
them the gospel.
Just because they aren't in a formalized
building with an organized liturgy
passing the offering plate doesn't mean
the substance of what the church does
isn't all present there. Yet, according
to the SDA church, what the Marys did
will one day be the mark of the beast
because it's part of Satan's plan for
you to worship Jesus on the first day.
just totally whacked thinking.
Nevertheless, this is what happens when
you do a surface skimmed over proof text
driveby method that Doug uses where he
just makes a bunch of assertions,
assumes his position is just a given,
and everyone else is confused, deceived
by Satan, or whatever else.
Oh, it's just talking about history. No,
dude. There's way more going on there
than history. The line's not drawn
there.
There's like way more theology going on
Just ridiculous.
Mark 16:9, a very similar reference. Now
when Jesus was risen on the first day of
the week, he appeared first to Mary
Magdalene. Do you find built into this
verse that it's there's a new
commandment?
No, there's nothing there. It's simply
the record of what happened. John 20,
very similar. The first day of the week
comes Mary early while it was still
dark. She came to the tomb. And just
again a historical record. There's no
new voice from a mountain, no new finger
writing new law in stone saying, "Now
the first day is to be our new Sabbath."
Nothing of the sort. Mark 16:1-2. Now
when the Sabbath was passed, Mary
Magdalene, Mary the mother of James, and
Saleom brought spices that they might
come and anoint him. Now, this to me is
actually proof that the seventh day was
still important.
If Jesus had taught the apostles that
they didn't need to keep the Sabbath
anymore or the seventh day wasn't going
to be important, it was not going to be
meaningful for them. Why was it so
important to the disciples that they
would not finish inbalming his body on
Friday when the sun was going down? They
knew Jesus would not be pleased with
that. There was a lot of work involved
in it. They said, "Let's wait until
after the Sabbath has passed." That's
why they waited because the Sabbath was
important. You know, Jesus even kept the
Sabbath in his death. He died Friday,
rested through the Sabbath, rose after
it was over. And so, the idea that it's
been done away with just doesn't hold
water. No new commandment here.
Okay. Oops.
No one is claiming that this verse has a
built-in commandment, Doug. Again, you
are unaware of why this verse is cited.
Just like in Matthew 28, John 20, and
Mark 16 both have the same Greek
construction regarding first day
Sabbath. That's one.
But did you notice his lack of
understanding around not just the new
creation, but also the sixth day being
preparation day?
Just like with Israel, they followed the
pattern of the sixth day being
preparation day. So, the disciples and
Marys did the same. All of that stuff
hearkens back to God on the sixth day of
creation.
Jesus is in the work of redemption.
There's a parallel going on to creation
in redemption.
The whole hinge of this is new creation.
God was teaching
his creation in this behavior. It wasn't
just arbitrary. It was pointing us to
Jesus. Yes. Even in creation,
the plan of redemption wasn't an
afterthought. From the beginning, this
was the plan. But also, the disciples
prior to the resurrection were in the
old creation, Doug, the tail end of it.
Yes, they observed the seventh day
Sabbath during that period. But you know
what? You didn't mention that after the
resurrection, Jesus himself changed that
habit. You guys never mention this.
There's no record of him observing the
old creation memorial post resurrection.
You guys will try and appeal to the book
of of Acts to claim they worshiped in
the synagogue on the Sabbath, completely
missing. That wasn't a Christian church
service. It was evangelism.
The disciples were not worshiping Jesus
alongside Jews who rejected Jesus as the
Messiah.
We were just in Acts 14 in our family
worship time.
Paul's dragged out and stoned by them
for preaching Christ and him crucified
in the synagogue.
which should cause you to ask, if they
were evangelizing to Jews on the 7th day
Sabbath, when were they in church?
But Mark 16 1-2 and John 20:1 are more
examples of the Greek language saying
first day Sabbath like in Matthew 28:1.
That's why you have Greek grimarians and
theologians that point to these verses
in conjunction with other stuff I've
pointed out. Oh, but that no rhyme or
reason, right?
They just want to hide their eyes from
the truth. No, Doug. I think you guys
want to hide your eyes from the truth to
uphold your tradition for fear that if
all your guys' conspiracies aren't true,
Adventism completely falls apart and
down comes the house of cards.
Then he made the classic Jesus kept the
Sabbath in the tomb claim.
We just addressed this a couple weeks
ago. I'm not going to go super deep on
this. You can go watch that video. No,
he was working on redemption in death,
not resting.
He rested after resurrecting when the
work was finished
which is why he is seated in heaven.
SDAs have a false Christology and don't
understand that Jesus's divine nature
did not die when his human nature did.
He was alive in the same way he was he
was he was alive in the same way that he
was before he incarnated when he died.
Death was a part of the work of
redemption, Doug. and works of necessity
were permitted on the Sabbath, of which
the redemption of all things was most
certainly the ultimate act of mercy.
I got two got to back up one. All right.
Very early in the morning on the first
day of the week, they came to the tomb
when the sun had risen. Again, it's just
telling us what happened there. And then
the next reference is in Luke. Luke
23:56
says, "They returned and they prepared
spices and fragrant oils. They rested on
the Sabbath day according to the
commandments." So they prepared that was
the preparation day. They got everything
ready. That's what we would call Friday.
They they kept the Sabbath according
Does he say the Jewish law? Luke was a
gentile. He says the the Sabbath. He
states it like every Christian will know
about this. And he's writing this years
after the crucifixion. He could have
said the old Jewish Sabbath. He says,
'According to the commandment, not the
old commandment, it's all stated as
though it's still in existence. Now, on
the first day of the week, very early in
the morning, they came to the supplr,
the tomb.
Is there anything in here that says,
"And God established a new Sabbath day."
So, we're looking at all the references
to the first day. We're looking for that
commandment. I know one evangelist was
very dramatic when he would preach on
this subject. He would, you know, bring
a thousand dollars and he'd put it up up
front for everyone to see it. And he
said, "I'm going to give this away to
anybody tonight that can show me this
missing text in the Bible. What I want
from you is to show me one commandment
in the Bible to keep the first day as
the new Christian Sabbath." Of course,
everybody's very quiet because it's not
there. And he always got to take his
money home.
So, he was happy doing that.
Yeah. No, you're just paring at Jones
there, Doug, who who had this whole
thing. I could do that same thing. I've
got $10,000 for any person that can show
me one verse that says verbatim, "Go to
church on Saturday. Oh, I'll get to
always take my money home." Yeah,
congrats. Again, Doug does not
understand the new creation, so he
appeals to a time in the old creation
right before the new was inaugurated by
Jesus's death.
This poses zero problems for the first
day position. Completely consistent.
That's what we would expect them to see
in the old creation.
Adventists love this verse thinking it's
a home run when no. This was on the
timeline of the old creation.
With regards to Luke 23, preparation day
started back in creation
and was teaching us something.
All throughout redemptive history, on
preparation day, all necessary work was
done ahead of time to enable worship on
the Sabbath, like in Exodus 31. Same
thing here in Luke 23. In the original
creation week, God's preparations
included preparing a home, Eden, and a
community, Adam and Eve, in which to
worship. Israel's preparation day, the
disciples preparing the body, etc., was
based on God's activities himself and
pointed to Jesus.
I mean, with the apostles, he's
literally there. It
deliberately created Adam prior to those
two preparations of preparing a home and
community.
Luke 24:1 is another arguably first day
Sabbath translation for the exact same
reasons I talked about with earlier that
that Philip Kaiser explains.
It is not just waxed over like as Doug's
portraying it here. And he's saying at
the beginning of this, I'm gonna try and
deal with it. You're not dealing with
anything. You're just citing the verse
and then making assertions, just
assuming all of your SDA
presuppositions.
And it all is rooted in you guys not
understanding the day is a part of the
ceremonial form. Days are not eternal.
They appealed to people like the
Puritans
who claimed, for example, the ten
commandments are eternal. Well, what did
they mean by this? Well, they meant
they're a reflection of who God is.
They're the antithesis of him. He's not
a liar, for example.
He's not a thief.
There's only one God, no idolatry, etc.
Not that there days are eternal
and the seventh day Sabbath was
governing heaven and and this expanse,
but no, you're missing it. The substance
of the fourth commandment is that the
one true god after the first three
commandments before it because the first
four are god-facing.
Is that you're you're not to worship any
other god. You're to not worship him in
a false way, the second commandment.
You're not to do so by taking his name
in vain, the third commandment. And
you're to all lot a portion of time out
of your focuses to dedicate to him
because he's worthy of it. That's the
eternal aspect is that he's worthy of
his image bearers time.
not the seventh day.
And yes, it does change. The form
changes in scripture. I'm sorry,
Adventists. It changes. Sorry.
That's what happens in the second giving
of the law. It's not rooted in creation.
That's a part of the form of the command
changing. The day is a part of the
ceremonial form.
And yes, Doug, Luke is documenting down
history. So obviously, he's going to
state it as it was. Doug.
So if I were to document down church
history from the 1200s, for example,
and I were to to write it as it were
back then, that means I'm saying it's
still to be that way today. No, he's
documenting history. He isn't
editorializing.
But again, did you catch the verbatim
fallacy?
That isn't an argument, Doug. No one's
claiming, "And then so therefore this is
a new commandment.
And you guys don't apply the same
standard for the vast majority of your
own teachings.
Show us one verse verbatim that says
investigative judgment or health reform.
Show us one verse that says verbatim go
to church on Saturday.
Not going to find it, so it must not be
there. Right? Of course, now all of a
sudden you're going to appeal to to
looking at the whole of scripture using
inference and deduction, not the
verbatim proof proof text fallacy. Now
we'll go to the sixth reference text uh
referring to the first day of the week
and it talks is it a new Sabbath day.
This is talking about the day of the
resurrection. It says then that same day
at evening. Now wait what day is this?
First day. When does a day begin and end
in the Bible?
So when it's talking about the same day
that Christ rose first day of the week
evening it's getting ready to turn into
Monday.
See what's happening? When the doors
were shut, the disciples were assembled
for to to inaugurate a new Sabbath. Is
that why they're assembled? It says
they're assembled for fear of the Jews.
The Jews were saying the body was
stolen. They thought they were going to
come looking for them. And Jesus came,
met with them, said, "Peace to you."
Now, you also look later, I think it's
verse 26 in the same chapter. It says 8
days later he met with them again. This
time Thomas is there.
What is 8 days after Sunday?
Seven days after Sunday would be what?
Sunday. 8 days after Sunday is Monday.
So he also meets with them on a Monday.
Is that a new Sabbath?
So the idea because Jesus did something
and met with the disciples, he met with
them by the sea when they were fishing.
Obviously, if they were fishing, it
wasn't the Sabbath, but he met with them
then, too. He met with them over a
period of 40 days after the
resurrection.
Okay, so classic claim from SDAs. They
don't understand that 8 days later is
one week because the Jews counted
inclusively.
Doug and SDAs are that say this are
basically just regurgitating what SDA
pioneer GI Butler claimed in his book,
The Change of the Sabbath. Notice notice
here what he asserts.
Quote, "This scripture talking about
John 20:26
in connection with the one just noticed
is relied upon to prove that it was the
practice of Jesus to meet with his
disciples on the first day of the week
between his resurrection and his
ascension. It will be noticed that the
record does not say that it was on the
first day of the week when Christ had
this interview with Thomas and the
disciples. The statement is that it was
after 8 days
from the previous meeting. That previous
meeting was at the very close of the
first day. Most of it probably occurring
on the day following. Oh, like Doug
said, it's claimed that the expression
after eight days signifies just a week.
But what proof is there of this?
Close quote. So, just like Doug, Mr.
Butler claims the text doesn't say Jesus
met with Thomas on the first day and
that after 8 days that doesn't signify a
week.
Let this be a a testimony, folks, to the
simple errors that many of these
pioneers fell prey to. Notice what Dr.
Sam Waldron says in his book, The Lord's
Day. I don't agree with Dr. Waldron on
everything. That's fine. But he explains
what's being said very simply. Notice,
quote, we note first the phrase in John
20:26, 8 days later, since the Jews
counted inclusively,
this eighth day was the first day of the
week. John is careful to include these
details of time because they point to
his Lord's Day theology, Revelation
11:0.
In fact, four of the eight New Testament
references to the first or Lord's Day
are in the Johannian literature on the
New of the New Testament. Close quote.
The Jews counted inclusively.
In effect, John is saying on the eighth
day, which is also in line with the eth
day motif all throughout scripture. So
they counted Sunday, Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
Sunday
8 would be Sunday.
Counting inclusively simply means that
you count the first day you used in the
numbering. You wouldn't say Sunday to
Monday, Monday to Tuesday, etc.
Doug, why do we have no dated cases of
Jesus corporately gathering on the
seventh day Sabbath post his
resurrection?
It's only the first day that we have
dated documented cases of
the reality is Jesus instituted this
practice with his disciples over the
course of the 40 days that he was here
before ascending.
The spirit is then poured out on the
first day which is Pentecost
where they were all in one accord.
And they simply continued the practice
that Jesus himself instituted just like
Ignatius also claimed happened.
Both scripture and history align on this
before the resurrection. Yes, Jesus
observed the seventh day Sabbath. That
was during the old creation period where
he was working on redeeming the
creation. After his accomplishment of
redeeming the creation and entering his
rest on the first day, he no longer
upheld that habit,
why didn't the Holy Spirit make sure to
canonize any sort of 7th day
significance post his resurrection?
But again, he doesn't even recognize the
same thing as Matthew 28. It's corporate
gathering of the body on the first day
with worship taking place.
So a week after he first appears to the
disciples of which Thomas was not there,
Jesus then appears uh the following
Sunday and appears to him. No, it wasn't
Monday. And Thomas worships him just
like Mary. They were corporately
gathered as the body of believers. Jesus
is present. Thomas hears the word of God
spoken over him. He believes it and
worships the Lord, my Lord and my God.
That's the substance of what the church
does on Sunday. Sir, talking about them
hiding from persecution does not negate
this. Has no bearing on this. That's
just another detail. It's not mutually
exclusive. Like, oh, if they were hiding
from persecution, it couldn't be that
the substance of everything the
Christian church does on Sunday is
present. No,
no one denies that they were gathered
for fear of persecution potentially. I
don't think the text actually says that,
but I think his I think it could be
deduced.
The point is they were gathered and
Thomas Thomas Thomas worships him. It's
the first day. That's the point. You
guys claim that will be the mark of the
beast one day because the pope is going
to enact a Sunday worship mandate which
will now make what doing make doing what
Mary's the Marys and Thomas did worthy
of damnation. Totally ludicrous.
Does this seventh passage say that
Sunday is holy?
And that passage is
1 Corinthians 16:2. We've only got one
more after this. Now, this is one some
people use. They say this is proof that
the disciples were now keeping Sunday as
a new Christian Sabbath. Paul says, "On
the first day of the week," and the way
it actually reads in the original, "On
the beginning of the week, let each one
of you lay something aside, storing up
as he may prosper, that there be no
collections when I come." Paul is on his
way through Asia. He's on his way to
Jerusalem to take a special offering
from the churches in Jerusalem. He's
making haste. There's a famine. They're
hungry. And he said, "Look, at the
beginning of the week, they used to get
their accounts in order in the first of
the week. Everybody sets something aside
when you've done your bookkeeping. So,
there is no church offering when I
come." It's actually saying the very
opposite. This is not talking about
passing the plate Sunday morning. He's
saying the beginning of the week, lay
something aside so that we don't have a
collection when I come. It's ready to
give to me and I'm making haste and I'm
on my way. Does this is this the new
Sabbath commandment?
Does he say anything here about now do
not work on that day? Uh make sure that
we gather together for worship on that
day. It has it's just a practical um
recommendation that they set aside an
offering for collection purposes.
Did you notice that his claim in the
original? It says, "Why doesn't he use
that standard across the board?"
I agree. What did the original author
intend to communicate, Doug?
That's what I care about. I want to know
what Paul, who was inspired, intended to
write and what he meant by that.
Which is why I seek to learn from those
that can deal with the text on on that
level. Which is why I then have to ask
Doug, who is claiming that 1 Corinthians
16 says Sunday is holy.
Whether or not a person believes that,
you don't have to be getting that from 1
Corinthians 16 or claiming the text says
that.
Again, this shows either dishonesty on
your part or ignorance because I don't
know anyone who claims this passage
states that Sunday is holy. Therefore,
that's why Sunday is the the the new
creation Sabbath or anything along those
lines.
I'm actually going to go out on a limb
and say I think he's just ignorant and
hasn't actually studied what the claims
are. He's just a great ortor and just
parrots information.
And again, after he appeals to the
verbatim fallacy, he then says Paul was
on a journey to Jerusalem. He was in a
hurry to take a special offering. There
was a famine, etc. The text says nothing
about a famine.
It doesn't verbatim say this was for the
poor because of a famine.
So don't hold others to a standard you
yourself don't.
The Greek grammar and the context of the
passage are what should drive the
understanding. What it evidences is that
one, New Testament daykeeping is a thing
and two that it's to be the first day.
When Paul says, "As I've given orders to
the churches of Galatia, so you must do
also.
On the first day of the week, let each
one of you lay something aside."
So this is in what's called the present
active imperative in Greek.
What does that mean? Very simple. An
imperative is simply a command. And the
present active simply means it's to be
ongoing. So what Paul says here is a
command that is to be ongoing for the
Christian church. It wasn't just to
Galatia and to first Corinth the the
churches in Corinth. That's basically
what it means. So no, Doug is wrong. It
isn't a practical recommendation. It is
a command.
Notice that Paul wanted the offerings
taken on a certain day which is tied to
the command.
It was something the Corinthians must do
and something that was universally
mandated for all Christians, even us
today.
According to the SDA interpretation,
this would make no sense because they
claim it's about setting money aside for
Paul when he then comes through for a
charity to then take to Jerusalem.
It only makes sense as an imperative
when it's understood that it's about
continual church. church practice.
Was Paul coming through weekly to pick
up charity set aside
and they were to continue doing that as
a command?
Notice again what Dr. Kaiser says
in his book.
He says, quote,
"Seventh day Adventists have tried to
say that this passage is only talking
about setting aside some money in the
home on each payday and that the first
day of each week was probably payday."
As Gordon Fees notes about uh Adolf
Diceman, he's a German theologian if I'm
pronouncing that right. But
Adolf Diceman put forth this suggestion,
but acknowledged that it had no known
support.
It seems altogether too modern to have
merit. Not only does it not have
support, but there is much evidence that
laborers were paid on a daily basis.
See, for example, Leviticus 19:13, where
employers were not allowed to wait till
the next day to make payment. See also
Matthew 21-16.
There is no getting around the religious
significance of the first day, no matter
how you translate the Greek. Notice,
too, that the context indicates that
this is an order to the churches. Verse
one, this is church practice in other
nations as well. verse one.
That's what's being addressed. Not
private charity. Close quote. No known
support
for the idea of the first day being
payday or the text being in reference to
such. This passage like the rest of the
letter is not about personal charity.
It's about instruction for the church,
church polity.
It wasn't contained to just Corinth or
Galatia, but all Christians. So this
passage is cited in this context because
it is indicative that the church was
gathering on the first day and Paul
gives this command in conjunction with
that
not because it verbatim says Sunday is a
new holy day. this is a new command or
the other straw man that he's put up
in his commentary on 1 and 2 Corinthians
19th century uh Princeton theologian I
love Charles Hodgej he comments on this
the the command to lay aside money
notice what he says
quote to the interpretation that
individuals should store up in their
houses
that's what the SDA church is is saying
it may be objected that the whole
expression is thus obscure and awkward.
The words do not mean to lay by at home,
but to lay by himself.
What he has to do with it and where he
has to deposit it is not expressed.
The word in Greek means putting into the
treasury
or hoarding up and is perfectly
consistent with the assumption that the
place of deposit was some common
treasury and not every man's home. If
Paul directed this money to be laid up
at home, why was the first day of the
week selected? It is evident that the
first day must have offered some special
facility for doing what is here
enjoined.
The only reason that can be assigned for
requiring the thing to be done on the
first day of the week is that on that
day that on that day the Christians were
accustomed to meet and what each one had
laid up aside from his weekly gains
could be treasured up, put into the
common treasury of the church.
The end which the apostles desired to
accomplish could not otherwise have been
effected. He wished that there might be
no collections when he came, but if
every man had his money laid by at home,
the collection would still be made. The
probability is therefore Paul intended
to direct the Corinthians to make a
collection every Lord's day for the poor
when they met for worship. Close quote.
Did either Kaiser or Hajj say the text
claims Sunday is a new holy day?
These are theologians, not not Joe Schmo
down the street pastor who probably has
great intentions but just isn't learned
because well theology is a vast category
like yeah pastors aren't perfect
but this is not why that's not why
people point to this verse Doug new
creation and the whole of redemptive
history are what are looked at to arrive
at this conclusion not single verses
like this these single verses are simply
supplemental to show yes the early
church was gathering on the first day.
And Charles Hodgej most assuredly knew
the Greek language better than GI Butler
and Doug Bachelor. That doesn't mean
he's automatically correct. But to claim
they have no rhyme or reason. Remember
that's what he said. They have no rhyme
or reason for any of this is just
laughable.
It has nothing to do with wild
conspiracies about hating God's law
being used by Satan or any of that.
So yes, Doug, this is evidence that the
disciples were keeping Sunday. Not just
that, but Paul's words command such.
Command such. It's not commanding that
you at home set aside money.
It is commanding that every Lord's day
you were to be putting up an offering
into the common treasury at the church
while you're gathered on the first day.
A command that you guys do not uphold,
but actively disregard.
Oh, and if you disagree with us, well,
you hate God's commands. You just don't
believe the Bible and so on, right? It's
what you guys tell us when we disagree
with your faulty interpretation.
So, what if I just did the same to you?
Would that be fair?
All right. Does the eighth, there's
question seven. This is the eighth now
in the final reference to the first day
of the week that you're going to find in
the Bi Bible, and people work real hard
to make hay out of this one. Um, is it
saying that Sunday is a new holy day?
Let's look at it together. It's Acts
20:7. If you've got your Bibles, I
recommend you turn there. Acts 20:7,
Luke is telling a remarkable story.
We'll find out why he's telling the
story. Now, on the first day of the
week, yes, that would be Sunday, when
the disciples came together to break
bread. Ah, there you got it. They came
together to break bread. They're having
a communion service.
They're gathering on the first day and
they're having a communion service. This
must be evidence that they now are
worshiping on the first day. It is the
new Sabbath. Uh I respectfully disagree.
I don't think that's what they're saying
at all. It says Paul is ready to depart
the next day. He speaks to them and he
continues his message till midnight.
Now
when does the first day begin?
Sundown. So when it says that they're
meeting on the first day of the week and
it's an evening meeting, what this is is
a Saturday night meeting.
And why is he talking so long? Because
he's not he's beginning a journey the
next day. If Sunday is a new Sabbath,
why is he beginning a journey?
Let's keep reading.
First of all, the scholar Horatio
Hackett said, "The Jews reckon the day
from evening to morning that on that
principle the evening of the first day
of the week would have been our Saturday
night." By the way, this uh scholar is
not a member of our church. He's just
being honest. The apostle held his last
religious service on Saturday evening
and consequently resumed his journey on
Sunday morning. Commentary on the book
of Acts. So Acts 20 it says a young man
named Udicus was sitting in the window
who's sinking into a deep sleep. He
falls down from the third story and he's
taking up dead because Paul was long in
preaching which is a good recommendation
for pastors not to preach too long
because it can be lethal when that
happens.
So Paul goes down he embraces the young
man. He says his life is still in him.
Udicus is resurrected. Luke is telling
this story because he's saying a
resurrection took place. Notice what
happened when they came up after Udicus
is resurrected. They broke bread. Now
they're breaking bread again. They eaten
and talked a long while even till
daybreak. They stayed up all night long.
They ate bread twice.
And then Paul depart the next day. Oh,
by the way, breaking bread in Acts 246.
Do you only break bread on uh
what does breaking bread mean? Is it
always a communion service? So
continuing daily with one accord in the
temple and breaking bread daily in the
temple daily breaking bread from house.
Jesus said give us this day our daily
bread. Breaking bread did not always
mean a communion service. It meant
eating. You remember on the road to
Emmas he went in and broke bread with
them. They were eating and that was a
Sunday night which would have been
Monday. So it's not saying anywhere in
these verses that Sunday is now a new
Sabbath. They ate their bread with
gladness, simplicity of heart. The next
day Paul said goodbye to them. He began
a journey. That would have been Sunday.
Would that be when you begin a long epic
journey? No. The prior day Sabbath he
spent with him all day. And that evening
he preached. L Udicus fell out the
window. He's resurrected. That's why
Luke is telling the story. He's not
telling the story to say a new Sabbath
was inaugurated in Acts chapter 20.
No, this isn't a Saturday night meeting.
Acts 20:6 says it was 5 days after
unleaven bread that Paul arrived in
Trrowaz.
Unleaven bread was on a Thursday using
the same method of inclusive counting.
That means he arrived in Trrowaz on a
Monday and was there according to the
text one week. In this case, it says one
week, not eight days later.
He then delayed his hurried trip until
the following Monday so that he could
worship with the church on Sunday, which
is why they were gathered on the first
day.
If there's no significance to this first
day meeting, no, it's just they're just
it's just a Saturday night meeting
to to talk about documenting down a
resurrection.
If there's no significance to this first
day meeting, then why does the passage
not mention any other meetings in the
previous seven days, Doug?
Such as the seventh day Sabbath,
this isn't talking about a Saturday
night service for Paul to then travel on
Sunday. He arrived on Monday, delayed
his trip to worship with the church on
Sunday, and at that one week mark the
following Monday, continued his travels.
Wouldn't God have told us if one of the
Ten Commandments had been changed?
What do you think? How many of you heard
that they've changed the law now?
Highway 65, you can go 80 miles an hour.
Isn't that exciting? Did Did you hear
that? How many of you believe me? Nobody
believes the pastor.
Why don't you believe me? Because you
know that if the state is going to
change a major law that would affect
everybody's lives, they are responsible
to thoroughly announce that and
advertise it to avoid accidents, right?
Everyone's going to know about that.
Now, when God gave the Sabbath
commandment, he spoke with his I wish
they would go 80 miles an hour and 65
because it is sure slow after church
when you get out there by Pleasant
Grove. But after um God gave the
Sabbath, he speaks it with his voice. He
writes it with his finger in front of an
entire nation. If he's going to change
that, don't you think there'd be
something in the New Testament that
there there'd be some com some battle?
Look at all the argument that the Jews
had with the Christians over
circumcision.
You find that discussed all through the
writings of Paul. There was a great
debate over that. They had a great
debate about whether or not you could
eat food sacrificed to idols or not. But
you realize there's never a debate about
whether or not you should keep the
Sabbath. Jesus spoke a lot about the
Sabbath, but he never spoke about
whether or not it should be kept. He
spoke about how it should be kept. It
was always presumed it would be kept
because it's one of the ten
commandments. God's not going to change
one of the ten commandments without
making that very clear.
Paul said, "I have not shunned to
declare to you the whole council of
God." Now Paul is giving the whole
council of God. Why did Paul never say
anywhere, by the way, the new Christian
Sabbath is the first day of the week.
None of them say that. And
Doug, your prophetist claimed that Paul
wrote Hebrews. So there you go. Hebrews
4.
If you didn't utilize the verbatim
fallacy and you worked through the flow
of the text to see what the author is
saying.
Yes, that's what he tells us.
The day Christ entered his rest, which
was the first day, paralleled God in
creation who entered the seventh day.
Verse 9, Hebrews 4:9, the Sabatismos,
the Sabbath rest that remains is another
day in contrast to the seventh day.
Which means you can argue tooth and nail
all you want on what day it is, but we
know for certain it's not the seventh
day.
Christ's accomplishment restored what
Adam broke. It brought the starting of
the week with the Sabbath back into
harmony and memorializes that
accomplishment as we look toward the
eternal rest that we await to physically
enter into.
The law hasn't changed, Doug. Who's
claiming that? The ceremonial form of
the fourth commandment has changed. This
is what you guys miss which as we have
seen before the fall was the first day
of man's week. Jesus restored this. We
also see the form change in the second
giving of the law in Deuteronomy 5 where
the fourth commandment is rooted in
redemption and not creation. This is a
change Doug.
This all demonstrates that the form of
the command can change while the
substance remains the same.
The day is not the substance. The day is
a part of creation. You've already
recognized that the Sabbath was made for
man.
And days, you agreed, are a part of
creation. You said God created a day on
the seventh day. Even showing that the
seventh day was created, meaning it's
not eternal by definition.
The eternal aspect of the command is its
substance which is that God is worthy of
a portion of his image bearers's time.
We are to step away from his command for
us to subdue the earth aka work and to
worship him. This is because of who God
is by nature as the creator. It's
eternal because God is eternal. He
always was, always is, and always will
be worthy of our worship. And God did
announce this change, Doug.
He spoke through the psalter some 500
years after Joshua where he spoke of
another day. Hebrews 4.
He did so when he resurrected which
demonstrated the restoration was
successful and by telling us that Jesus
entered his rest that day. Hebrews 4:10.
He did so through all of the eighth day
motifs in the Old Testament that dealt
with new beginnings, new creation, first
fruits, etc.
It's literally all throughout scripture,
dude.
But it requires reading more than one or
two verses and getting past spiritual
meat or or milk to the meat of the
matter.
It is because you do not understand
creation and redemption and the work of
Jesus that he accomplished.
That's where the issue lies.
You may have a case for people who
reject the Sabbath outright,
but it doesn't work against the
Christian Sabbath position.
I don't know anyone who claims God
changed the ten commandments. You may
have some Christians that say the 10 are
not binding anymore and then Christian
sabotarians that recognize they do, but
not as a barometer for salvation like
SDAs do. Yet you keep crossing wires
between the two here.
He points out there being no controversy
surrounding the day of worship. Doug,
that's precisely the point.
There's zero controversy and argument
around the universal day of the church
gathering for corporate worship on the
first day. None. You had controversy
around all sorts of other things. Yet,
you didn't around this because it was
universally understood and recognized.
You guys claim there's this grand
conspiracy by Satan to deceive everyone.
Yet, we see no controversy over the fact
that the first day was being universally
observed both in the east and the west.
You guys can't deal with that either.
You want to say it's all this stuff
about Roman Catholicism. Okay, what
about in the East?
You don't know. You don't understand
church history.
If we don't assume your great
controversy worldview with all of its
extra details that contradict history
and scripture, what we see is that the
first day was universally practiced and
accepted with no controversy over this
change.
The same is said too, by the way, for
the inclusion of children in the
covenant. by the way, Adventists,
yet you guys don't administer the
covenant sign to children like you
should. Oh, that's all tradition.
Nevertheless,
if your position were true, Doug, it
should be the opposite.
It should be the exact opposite of what
you said, thinking that it's helpful
because you're assuming, well, all
Christians, like Ellen White said, all
Christians kept the seventh day Sabbath
like we did or like we do.
But just like when circumcision was
being discussed,
there should have been quarrels about
the Jewish Sabbath not being upheld by
some extensions of the body in both the
east and the west. We don't see it. And
all of history is on our side. There's
no controversy over it. Yet, if it was
this horrible thing, it should have been
coming up at a council. You just assume
that no Christians were keeping Sunday.
You just beg the question and assume
your position and then say, "So, isn't
it funny that we see no controversy?"
Man, the irony.
Again, I get I get that lots of SDAs,
they're okay with outright dismissing
all of history. Toss it into the can,
just ignore it. Christianity basically
came onto the scene in the 1800s.
And again, with the verbatim fallacy,
did Paul say the new Christian Sabbath
is the first day of the week? Yeah, he
kind of did, actually. He kind of did.
Luke and Paul distinguish between the
Sabbath and the first day Sabbath, which
eliminates any sort of confusion
regarding history when both Sabbaths
were being practiced. The 7th day
Sabbath by unbelieving Jews and the
first day Sabbath by the Christian
church. You guys love appealing, Doug,
to Acts 13:42
as a claim that the apostles kept the
seventh day Sabbath. This is one of
those instances in the New Testament
where it says they were in the synagogue
on the Sabbath. And SDAs always say,
"See, so they were keeping the Sabbath,
the seventh day Sabbath."
The SDA church even cites it on their
website on their fundamental uh belief
page regarding the Sabbath. But no, the
Sabbath with the Sabbath with Jews in
the in in the synagogue, that was
evangelism, not worshiping Jesus
alongside people who rejected him.
Nevertheless, the interaction in Acts
13:13-41
shows Paul reasoning with the Jews in
their synagogue on their Sabbath day.
They reject Paul's message, but then
Paul gave the same words to them on a
Sabbath in between the Jewish Sabbaths.
So question, what is that in between
Sabbath?
Look at John's D. Parker.
This is his comments on the Greek of of
Acts 13:42. And notice what he
highlights.
Quote,
"When Paul and Barnabas were at Antioch
in Pacidia on their first missionary
tour, we have the most indisputable
evidence of the transfer of the Sabbath
from Saturday to Sunday. Paul first
preached to the Jews in their synagogue
on the Jewish Sabbath. And when the Jews
were gone out of their synagogue, Acts
13:42, the Gentiles besought that these
words might be preached to them the next
Sabbath.
or the Sabbath in between
that is the Sabbath between the Jewish
Sabbaths and the narrative continues
Acts 13:44
and the next Sabbath day on the
following Sabbath just at hand came
almost the whole city together to hear
the word of God
when the participle
that's the verb is used in reference to
place in it design uh in reference ref
to like a place, it designates a place
that is near or next. As in Mark 138
where Christ said, "Let us go into the
next towns."
When the participle is used in reference
to time, it designates the next day, as
in Acts 21:26, where Paul took the men
and the next day purifying himself with
them entered into the temple. The
evangelist here says the following
Sabbath was between the Jewish Sabbaths
and near at hand, that is on Sunday. Can
language be framed that would prove the
transfer of the Sabbath from Saturday to
Sunday more clearly and indisputably
than this language of the inspired
evangelist? Close quote.
Ah, so Doug appealed to the original
language earlier for anthropos as well
as elsewhere in Acts. Well, Doug, when
you do that, we see not only that Paul
wasn't worshiping Jesus on the seventh
day Sabbath with the Jews who rejected
him, and that was evangelism, but that
there is a Sabbath in between.
This is the HGM, by the way, folks, the
historical grammatical method, the only
approved hermeneutic of the SDA church.
This is like one of their new favorite
things. I I just hear it constantly now
from pe from Ted Wilson, all over the
place now. They're like really ramping
this up.
Okay. Well, if you utilize that, that's
what John's D. Parker just did.
You look at the grammar, the history of
who it was being applied to, you arrive
at how they would have understood it,
and then derive modern-day application
from that.
The Sabbath in between is when the
Christian church would have been
worshiping.
So, Dr. Parker's shows that it's at
least possible that this is a valid
based on the original text as as Doug
put it earlier showing that again, no,
you don't even know the arguments, Doug.
You don't know what you're criticizing
and you need to stop telling people that
Christians have no basis in scripture
for their belief in this area.
You aren't using the HGM that your buddy
Ted said is the only approved
interpretation method of the SDA church.
Well, Mr. Parker did. And I want to know
what Luke wrote and intended to
communicate. Which means I want to know
how the grammar of the text is actually
functioning and what it would have meant
to a Greek speaker, not an English
speaker.
Praise God we have translations of the
text in our own language. But I want to
know what the author's intended meaning
was, not what I want to be true. I want
to know what the inspired evangelist or
apostle wrote,
which is what the historical
grammatical method is all about. When we
do that, we see Luke distinguishes
between the Jewish Sabbath and a Sabbath
in between the next Jewish Sabbath.
You're free to disagree with him. Go for
it.
But stop lying and saying Christians
have no rhyme or reason for their
belief. It's just like a guard that
stands post. I I don't even know why I
do what I do. I just No. You're a liar.
You're a liar.
And you need to stop it.
You don't even know the real issues and
arguments.
We're still waiting for even a mention
of new creation.
Genesis 1-2, Exodus 20, Deuteronomy 5, 2
Corinthians 5:17, Hebrews 4 1-11, John
5, Acts 20:7, Matthew 28:1, 1
Corinthians 16, Acts 13:42, John 20
verse1, Mark 16, but yeah, no biblical
support to arrive at the conclusion.
Yeah. Okay. What does most of the world
do?
Could the disciples have changed the
Sabbath even if they wanted to? Does
even a disciple have the authority to do
that? No.
Paul said, "You shall not add to the
word that I command you, nor take away
from it, that you may keep the
commandments of the Lord your God, which
I command you." In Revelation 22:1 19,
if anyone takes away from the words of
the prophecy of this book, God will take
away his part from the book of life. We
cannot change the word of God. Some
people think, "Oh, this Sabbath thing,
you're making a big deal out of a little
thing." Friends, I disagree. I think
this is the biggest kind of thing that
Christians ought to stand for. It is one
of the commandments of God. Someday
we'll all be judged by the commandments.
It says, "So do and so speak that those
who will be judged by the law of
liberty." That's what James tells us. Uh
Jesus said, "Heaven and earth, Matthew
5:18, will pass away before one jotted
tit passes from the law."
And then Christ said, "Whoever will
think to break one of the least of these
commandments and do so, he'll be spoken
of as least in the kingdom of heaven."
These are very important issues to God.
He said Paul and then cited Deuteronomy
4,
which clearly he meant Moses. I'm not
sure what his point was there. Clearly a
misspeak. But either way, yes, Doug,
that was during the old creation.
In the very next chapter, you would have
seen the form of the Sabbath command
change from being rooted in creation to
redemption. Did God write both with his
finger? You guys only ever focus on
Exodus 20, but miss this rather
important detail.
Apparently, aspects of it can change
because aspects of it have changed.
Now, he cited Revelation 22, saying that
first day sabotarians take away from the
words or change the words of the Bible
or really just Christians in general.
Uh, no, we don't. We reject your guys'
faulty interpretation and application of
scripture built on a bad hermeneutic
that doesn't even see the fuller picture
of scripture and wants everything in
verbatim sound bites and proof texts,
flatlining the Bible out when not
everything is in spiritual milk.
And secondly, Revelation 22 is about the
book of Revelation specifically. The
book was not compiled. The Bible was not
compiled at the time of John writing the
the apocalypse. It's in reference to
specifically the Revelation. But what's
funny about this is that in the clear
word or as we call it the blurred word,
Jack Blanco changes this exact verse in
Revelation. Notice
the clear word is supposed to be a King
James paraphrase.
Notice the KJV.
For I testify unto every man that
heareth the words of the prophecy of
this book. If any man shall add unto
these things, no clarifier, anything.
God shall add unto him the plagues that
are written in this book. compared to
the clear word which Jack Blanco
rendered. I John warn everyone who reads
or hears the prophetic words in this
book not to add anything contrary
to what is written.
If they do, God's seven plagues will
certainly fall on them. Jack Blanco
changed the biblical text which actually
says to not add anything. Period. Not
forbidding additions that are contrary.
So, how ironic that you cite this, Doug,
claiming Christians are in danger of
adding to and taking away from God's
word. Yet, the Bible paraphrase with
your church's stamp of approval on it
not only changes the word of God by
inserting Ellen White directly into the
text over and over and over again, but
the exact verse you cite to warn others
about.
So, maybe take a rain check on that one.
I know SDAs hate when the SDA church is
saddled with the clear word, but they
put their stamp of approval on it, not
me.
He said, "The biggest thing Christians
ought to stand for is the law." Doug,
doing so is irrelevant when you take a
stand for a false gospel and a false
Christ and a false prophet.
It is your guys's unlawful handling of
the law that leads to your false gospel.
Which is why the problem isn't the law,
but the way that you guys use it.
But further, your church doesn't even
keep half of the other commands.
They murder unborn children in your
hospitals. You have an idol, a false
gospel.
You yourself bore false witness earlier
multiple times.
You guys make depictions of what you
believe to be a person of the Godhead
violating the second commandment.
You yourself even having them at mass
scale at your own church during some of
your elaborate sermon series that you
do. I've seen them.
Yet you guys would say, "No, no, we
disagree with your interpretation and
application of the second commandment."
Ah, so just like we do with yours of the
fourth. Now deal with the substance of
what we're saying. namely the new
creation that your guys' system has no
present category for.
We also got more of the hopscotch exesus
all over the Bible with assertions.
None of what you cited, Doug,
impacts the Christian Sabbath position.
And again, this isn't utilizing the HGM,
which Ted Warren to be on the lookout
for. So Adventists mark and avoid Doug
Bachelor. I guess he's one of these
schismatics that Ted talked about.
He didn't use what Mr. Wilson says is
the only approved hermeneutic of the SDA
church. No, the SDA church, the SDA
Bible commentary, Ellen White, they have
put their stamp of approval on these
things. So, he has the green light that
oh, it's biblical.
Did you notice too he cited Matthew 5:19
regarding those who will be the least in
the kingdom? Doug, they're still in the
kingdom. They didn't fail to make it
because they didn't have the seventh day
Sabbath seal.
Nevertheless, Doug regularly lumps
together those who are first day
sabotarians with those who aren't, but
doesn't realize his arguments do not
impact the first day sabotarian at all.
The claim is not that the law changed.
The claim is that the ceremonial form of
it has changed, which for the thousandth
time we see taking place in redemptive
history as it's unfolding. The day is
not the substance of the command, Doug.
Days are a part of creation. You already
recognized it. You claim it's an eternal
thing. Yet you claim that it was made
for man and that man was created. Days
were created. It's necessary for the sun
and the moon which are a part of
creation etc. So you're straw mening
when you claim that the first day
sabotarians are changing the law of God.
No, we're recognizing the cere the
ceremonial form of the command changed.
The substance has and is the same as
it's always been. God is due worship and
we are to cease from our command to take
dominion which is our labors and give
him a due portion of worship. This takes
place from the memorial day that
memorializes that the the accomplishment
of redemption in the new creation. It's
the first day God in Christ entered his
rest that day resting restoring the
order prior to the fall.
It was God who ended his week with the
Sabbath and a preparation day beforehand
on the sixth day.
Man started his week on the Sabbath. You
yourself have even stated multiple times
tonight they counted evening to evening.
Ah
yeah,
his man man's week uh started with the
Sabbath where God ended his because it's
all about God's rest and man's
fellowship in that rest broke. That's
part of the promise. That's the the hope
that we have the esqueological rest that
awaits for us in eternity. Jesus has
gone in there ahead of us.
That's what it all points to. That's
what the memorial points to.
But then man broke this
due to sin with a curse then being
placed on creation where even the rest
of man became impacted by the fall and
Jesus restores that. But God then gave
the promise of the gospel in Genesis
3:15 which was a promise that Jesus
would destroy the works of the devil and
restore what man broke. All of it, not
just in this area.
The Sabbath served as a memorial of that
promise of Jesus to come redeem the
creation that fell. Which is why in
Exodus we see it rooted in creation and
Deuteronomy it rooted in redemption.
Both of those also are rooted in rest,
God's rest.
After Jesus did what God promised, he
entered his rest paralleling what the
triune God did in the original creation.
He ceased from his work because it was
done and entered into the eternal rest
of God that awaits his people to mediate
on behalf of them. The Holy Spirit is
then sent and given as a down payment
promise that he will return for his
people and we will receive that
inheritance and actually enter into the
true promised land.
That's what the memorial day in the new
creation points to
the accomplishment of God's promise in
Christ. what the old creation memorial
was also pointing to. Both of which
ultimately point to the eternal rest of
God that all people from the beginning
who are saved will enter into. So you
need to stop lying. Stop claiming
Christians have no basis for what they
believe, etc. My my my challenge to you
still stands.
Let's publicly debate this. We'll do it
at your church. I'll show up to
California. I'll come into your home
territory and I'll bring just my Bible
and we'll see who does and doesn't
understand scripture. Okay?
And we're not just going to rattle off a
bunch of verses and do the gish gallop
and machine gun out the proof text with
good ortor skills to try and wow an
audience. We're going to walk through
the verses and see what the author is.
We're going to utilize your own
hermeneutic that that Ted Wilson says is
the only hermeneutic. Let's do it, Doug.
Somebody get it set up. You get people
that comment on my videos. I've had
people that comment on the videos and
say, "I know Doug Bachelor. I used to
work for Doug." Okay, if you guys are
still watching, get it set up. I'll be
cordial. I'll be calm. I'm going to be
firm. But he needs to stop lying. And
Adventists need to stop lying. You might
disagree with an interpretation. You
need to stop pinning it on conspiracy
theories. And if you just watch this and
you continue to do it, you're bearing
false witness, proving that you're a
hypocrite and you're breaking and
violating all of the law in doing so.
So, you need to stop.
You might disagree with mine and others
interpretations of the text on this
topic. Okay, then let's discuss that.
But asserting your guys's favorite
slogans does nothing but rally up an
echo chamber. They changed the Bible.
It's all tradition. It's because of the
pope. They hate the go the law of God.
All that sort of stuff is just silly
rhetoric that does nothing.
Think about if my engagement folks with
SDA theology was on that level. Ellen
White has an obelisk on her tomb and
then use that to try and refute their
theological position.
Yeah, it wouldn't fly. They'd be in a
tizzy and rightly so because that's not
an apologetic.
Deal with the substance of what's
actually put forth, which is what we try
and do on this platform. actual source
material from I don't know anyone else
hired to go to the Barri, the Adventist
Theological Society, the president of
the SDA church, you know, people like
Doug Bachelor. I know he's not a
theologian. Again, I said that earlier,
but he has millions of people listening
to him and he needs to stop lying to
people. So, we will get to the rest of
this next week in part two looking at a
lot of history because he launches into
a full-on the classic SDA historical
revisionism. We will also look at other
greats through history who understood
this from scripture and some other
historical uh source documents that Doug
cites uh spoiler alert.
Clearly, he didn't vet them himself,
which is obvious after looking at them,
which we will do, but hopefully you were
able to see that the SDA church does not
understand what they criticize.
Christian, when they tout that we have
zero basis for why we do what we are
doing, we're Bible illiterate. Everyone
before them was duped by Satan etc.
Understand why
it is this sort of stuff that they are
hearing and pariting. This is not unique
to Doug. Steven Boore has given an
almost identical presentation on the
same subject. All the same claims, all
the same assertions, all the same proof
text, all in the same order.
I chose Doug because he happened to get
through it quicker than Steven Bore just
kind of drags on and on and on. But
sadly, Adventists have not actually been
taught what others actually believe
because most of them have inherited the
claims and arguments of their pioneers.
Then people like Doug Bachelor
blasted out in that world to millions of
people who then just regurgitate it.
You have to develop an understanding on
this topic that is deeper than just
proof text and little sound bites and
see the bigger picture of scripture and
the biblical narrative as a whole.
I'm talking to Christians when I say
that. Adventists, too. But Christian,
it's not going to work to just lob proof
text back and forth and and to do a
proof text war. That that does nothing.
It does nothing. You're not going to
reach SDAs by just lobbing out. And
well, I got my proof text and you have
your as if scripture is is contradicting
itself.
I didn't always feel this way about the
Sabbath, by the way. haven't always been
a first- day sabotarian, but as I
continued studying, this is where it
led.
Once you strip away all the great
controversy, worldview mess that the SDA
church is strapped onto the the doctrine
and see what scripture is actually
teaching,
it's a beautiful doctrine, which is why
I refuse to concede any of scripture
to them or any seventh day sabotarian on
this for that matter.
So take that for what you will. Sharing
is caring. Doug, my challenge still
stands. Let's make it happen.
You need to stop claiming we have no
biblical basis for for this when you
haven't even touched the real issues and
provided any sort of meaningful
interaction. The Sabbath is not the seal
of God. It's not a barometer for who is
and isn't saved. It isn't the final test
of loyalty in the end times. Your
prophet was wrong. Maybe if we debate,
you can also show me just one verse that
verbatim says that the mark of the beast
is going to be worshiping on Sunday
after a three-fold union between the
papacy, apostate, Protestantism, and
spiritualism is formed, forcing everyone
to recognize Sunday as the day of
worship and rest. Should be simple
because it's just one verse, right,
Doug? Just one verse. That's all we
need. Otherwise, it's not in the Bible,
right?
The Sabbath is about rest. Rest in
Christ who accomplished a mighty
miraculous act of redeeming the creation
that man broke. He did so successfully
and his uh through his sinless life,
death, burial, and resurrection, which
are a testament to that.
In the words of Pastor Nate Batik
from an article he just published
yesterday,
quote, "The Sabbath healing of the man
with the withered hand, Matthew uh 129
9-14, was tied to Jesus's gospel
invitation.
Come to me all who labor and are heavy
laden and I will give you rest. Take my
yoke upon me upon you and learn from me
for I am gentle and lowly in heart and
you will and you will find rest for your
souls. Matthew 11:28-29.
Jesus purchased esqueological Sabbath
rest for his people by taking upon
himself the judgment they deserve when
he hung under the wrath of God on the
cross.
Picking up on Psalm 95:7-11,
the writer of Hebrews alludes to the
abiding hope of entering into eternal
rest in glory with Christ since Jesus
entered into his everlasting rest.
Hebrews 37
through 4:12.
Pastor Nick, your article was excellent.
The Sabbath is ultimately about the
gospel, folks.
trusting in the person and finished work
of Christ in redemption,
celebrating that on the memorial of the
new creation when that work was
accomplished
with those who it was accomplished for
the body
and looking forward to his return when
we will physically enter into God's
rest, the promised land, the true
promised land. I long for that day.
But only those resting in the true
gospel will enter.
That is the delineating mark.
That is the dividing line between those
who truly worship God and those who do
not. Those who are sealed by the Holy
Spirit that are born again, not the
seventh day Sabbath. Believe the gospel,
friends. Believe it. Thanks for being
here. Like I said, we'll get into part
two next week. As always, until next
time, God bless.
[Music]